Hold us.
All the good stuff happens before you
know he's does three,
two,
one.
Okay.
Dan Carlin,
ladies,
gentlemen.
And we're live.
Hey Dude.
First of all,
thank you so much for this coin.
This coin from Constantine.
You brought me,
uh,
how many years old?
1700.
That's fucking crazy,
man.
It's fun to,
I always say I like giving something
that is the oldest manmade objects in
most people's homes.
Maybe not yours.
You'll have some aboriginal instrument
or something that's like from the Stone
Age,
but most people that'll be the oldest
manmade thing in their home.
My friend,
Dr.
Mark Gordon actually gave me a Roman
coin as well,
but I dunno who's coin is all yours.
Looks older.
I don't know.
That's depressing though.
Cause normally I'm the coin guy so I
hate that I've been beaten to the punch
by anybody on that.
Well he's,
he's kind of a historical efficient auto
or a history aficionados.
Well not the extent that you are though,
but so this is from Constantine?
Yeah,
my wife would spend that by accident.
Just so you know.
Oh,
I got a coffee.
I got a pair of shoes.
That's right.
And there were no,
wouldn't buy shoes?
No.
W W how much was that worth back then?
Do you know what that's like?
There probably is.
It is.
Did they have,
what kind of units do they have?
Like A,
they probably had like some dead metal
type thing and then some kind of bronze
and then you get into the silver and
gold and how much is mixed into the rest
and uh,
and they have those like you can go and
it's actually really cool because they
were better like,
like they'll,
they'll clean the silver often it looks
like yesterday.
So you always know what's the cheap
stuff when they're all dirty and
everything like that.
Oh,
right.
Because then that's like a penny.
Well,
our pennies get the same way.
Right.
What do you think this is made out of?
Oh,
some alloy.
I Dunno,
they had alloys back then.
Oh,
sure.
Electrum was the cool,
when were you mixed?
Gold and silver.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I've never heard of that.
Electrum they still have,
they still do.
They use it.
If,
I hope I'm right about this,
this is gonna be one of these is on
twitter.
Can Carly doesn't know what he's talking
about it about electron.
It's not bad.
Well,
the beautiful thing about your podcast
is you can research things in advance so
you know what the fuck you're talking
about.
By the time you speak when you're
radically.
Yes,
allegedly.
I supposedly,
I have a lot of,
a lot of wiggle room words,
defensive journalism.
Yeah,
but the,
I don't have to tell you again,
but I will.
Your,
your podcast is for me,
has been the most educational historical
thing in my entire life.
I've never had anything in my life that
it's taught me more about history than
hardcore history.
I don't even know how to react when
people say that.
It is the kindest things that you hear.
And I always say the same thing.
I always hope everybody gets a chance in
their lives to have people that they
admire turning around and telling them
something like that.
Cause it is the need is feeling.
And when,
when you realize all the crap you put up
with for decades and other jobs and
other businesses to say,
okay,
I'm 51 or whatever,
and they really like what you do.
You just,
everybody should feel this way.
So I appreciate that though.
You my pleasure and I appreciate you.
You,
you found your niche,
man.
You like,
think about all the other stuff you did,
all the broadcast work you did before.
It really prepared you for this,
this podcast,
because obviously this medium is so
incredibly new and this ability for you
to just put something out.
I mean,
I see when you put out new podcasts,
they're at the top of the heap of all
the podcasts in the world.
That's incredible.
When you think about that,
that all you,
it's just you and you have a,
an a guy who helps you with editing
theoretically.
Yeah.
And that's fucking it.
I mean,
that is amazing.
how is that any different from this
empire?
You've this,
cause I'm just talking.
That's all I'm doing too.
But you walk into this place,
you go,
this is,
this is the Joe Rogan's talking has
built,
yeah,
something,
something along those lines.
Talking to people like you,
but you're right.
I mean I keep trying to remind myself
because you know,
you and I both been doing this a long
time,
got into it pretty,
pretty early on and so for us it doesn't
feel new,
but you keep trying to think about,
okay,
what's this going to be like in 30
years,
40 years?
I keep telling everybody that.
What you're seeing now in Mike,
my children,
no,
no other world.
I mean in their minds,
I tell my oldest all the time at at the
time you were born,
we weren't even texting yet.
That is all since you've come around.
So I keep thinking we're at still at the
tip of the tip of the tip of the iceberg
in this era that we're in now.
What's podcasting going to be like when
whole generations grow up and it's just
a part of their world and podcasts are a
part of it and it won't even be
podcasting.
I mean there'll be broadcasting into the
matrix cord in the back of your neck or
something.
But,
but I mean,
we're still at the,
it seems hard for longterm podcasters to
understand that this is still the
beginning.
It's almost impossible for us to predict
because when you really think about what
we're doing now in terms of like,
like you could put a youtube video right
now,
you could make a video and you could,
it could go viral for whatever reason,
and a million people all over the world
to be watching your video.
Like almost instantly.
This was not,
uh,
not only unheard of 10 years ago.
Just go back 20,
30,
40.
It's insanity.
You're talking insanity.
Like people would be like,
what the fuck are you saying?
You have a phone in your pocket?
That would be insane.
You have a phone in your pocket that has
a camera.
What?
You wait,
don't you have a phone in your pocket?
That's a video camera that takes high
definition video with stereo sound and
you can we meet,
you're uploading it through the sky just
through the air.
What in real time.
Instantaneously.
That's insane.
So now think,
what could we be looking at in terms of
augmented reality in terms of virtual
reality and working on something along
those lines.
Right now it's,
it's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
It's what you doing.
I can't tell you what I'm doing.
Tell me off.
No,
but,
but the point of the podcast up,
the point is,
is that this,
this,
you're absolutely right about this
stuff.
And,
and you,
you know,
I spent,
before I got into podcasting,
I was in,
uh,
in the era where,
you know,
like Mark Cuban made it big and
everybody was just going to start a high
tech company and sell it for billions of
dollars.
What did Cuban make it big with a
broadcast.com
I think,
which,
which we call it was basically like a
website with a bunch of links and,
and you know,
everybody was like,
Dang,
if he can do so.
So I was in one of these companies with
a bunch of buddies and we were,
we were pushing what we called amateur
content back then.
So we're talking 95,
96.
And one of my jobs was to go with the
staff to all these venture capitalists
and try to sell them on the idea of what
amateur content was going to become.
Joe,
we went from like place to place to
place with all these people who are
supposedly the,
who can see the future and every one of
them.
And I mean every single one said
nobody's going to view amateur content
because if anybody could make anything,
anybody would wanted to see,
they'd be paid for it.
And I kept talking about the quantity
has a quality all its own idea,
right?
Where you say,
listen,
if only 1% of this stuff is worth
watching,
you're still going to have millions of
pieces of content uploaded all the time.
There's going to be good stuff in there.
And they were like,
you.
So you thought this was coming.
It was in some ways.
Well.
Yeah,
and it wasn't just because,
um,
you know,
I was in with a bunch of tech people who
understood this too,
but one of them had taken me off the
radio and said,
we're going to put you on the Internet.
This was in 94.
And I said,
put me on the Internet.
I said,
you know,
we're just learning how to use the,
I said,
what are we going to do?
And you just,
well,
I'm going to invent the,
the way to do this and you going to be
the test person,
right.
That shows everybody,
hey,
you could,
so that fell through.
But once that happened,
I was,
you know,
it was in the back of my head going,
okay,
someday we might be able to do this on
the Internet,
that kind of thing.
But,
but the,
the point was is that these people do
venture capital meetings.
All these hardcore guys were inventing
our future and funding it.
None of them saw this amateur content.
Then coming,
there was one thing that they were doing
quite a long time ago.
There was like some Internet radio
channel because they had tried to put
together and you know,
they had funded it and spend a bunch of
money on,
they hired a bunch of people to do it
and Bobby Slayton was actually one of
the,
uh,
the online broadcasters and I did his
show and he didn't know and he was
talking about how they were having a
hard time keeping it up and wasn't
catching on the way they wanted to.
They were just a little bit ahead of
your head too far.
I read somewhere too,
cause I was actually sort of researching
the history of what we do and what the
precursors were.
And I guess there were audio blogs and
stuff that some really high tech types
where we're pursuing in the 90s also.
And maybe even the late eighties where,
you know,
they're like send in full files to each
other or something.
But you know,
it's funny because somebody is going to
write a book someday about the history
of this and how it got started and all
that kind of stuff.
And it's crazy to think about that.
We're actually due to sort of a
serendipity.
Good,
good timing sense that here we are,
like I said in the first 10 years,
15 years of of what's not just going to
be a phenomenon,
but it's going to be a huge part I think
of the future world that people grow up
and not our show specifically but,
but,
but this world we're creating,
I mean everyone's a broadcast or now.
Yeah.
And look,
anyone could have been,
I mean there's been a lot of barriers to
keep people that are really talented,
interesting,
funny people from getting their stuff
out there.
And that thing was like always like they
didn't know how to start.
How do I like how do I become a standup
comedian enough to,
I've talked to so many funny guys and
they just go,
wow,
how do I get started?
I'm like,
well you got to go sign up at an open
mic night and like,
ah,
to seems too much.
And the,
the idea of it is too daunting.
But if you just sit in front of a
camera,
that's all you have to do.
Turn your cell phone on and start
talking.
Here's what I think about Donald Trump.
That is what I think about Harvey
Weinstein.
All you have to do is have a unique
take.
Be Funny,
be interesting,
somehow engaging.
And it doesn't even have to be visual.
I mean,
God,
there's a hundred maybe more really
funny what I would call twitter
comedians that just save funny shit.
They write funny shit on twitter and
they have huge followings because of it.
I always say,
you know,
you try to look at what the brick and
mortar analog version of this was before
this came around.
And Remember Mc Hammer was selling,
you know,
cassette tapes of his music out of the,
out of his hatchback at the Oakland a's
games or,
or I think of like Eddie Murphy or
Richard Pryor.
These people who are just,
they're so funny that you could put them
on a crappily recorded cassette tape and
it wouldn't make any difference.
And I,
and I remember Eddie Murphy saying
something about if he hadn't gotten on
Saturday night live,
he doesn't know how he would of how he
would have exposed himself to the
public.
Well,
these days,
if you're that funny and you put that on
audio and you put it out there,
you will,
you know,
know you no longer need the facilitator,
the gatekeeper to open the doors for
you.
You have a wide open,
um,
uh,
Mike,
you know,
you called it open Mike Nights.
This is open mic night for the world,
right?
Yeah.
Every country.
It's fucking crazy.
There's some kid who's 20 years old.
They bought a house in my neighborhood
for $9 million or $7 million.
$7 million.
I'm fucking youtube kid.
I was reading about it today.
I weigh what?
He's 20.
He bought a $7 million fucking house.
I was like,
this is insane.
Don't even pull it up enough of him.
No,
I was,
I was at Youtube Youtube about a month
ago.
I did a speaking engagement at Google
and across the street in New York above
the Camden market.
They own the whole building.
So they take me up there,
I get the six hour tour and at one point
they have on a wall with all these
youtube stars on it and you know,
I'm old,
so there's one or two.
So I go,
okay,
that's lady Gaga I guess.
And there's a bunch of like 20 year olds
and they're going,
oh,
this guy has a bazillion followers.
And I'm looking at him going,
really?
I mean at his age,
I don't know what the Hell I was doing.
I was taking a year off college or
something.
But it's all these kids with multiple
piercings and tattoos and face stuff and
they're all the Google people were
telling me,
Oh,
these people are all huge giant.
He's come in with their entourages and
that's great.
Yeah,
some kid just died.
He was 21 and saw in the paper these
tattoos and I was like,
what the fuck is this kid?
Well he said giant Youtube Star,
some Youtube Rep star.
Do you know?
Did you know who he was?
I've heard the name.
I didn't know.
See you're,
you're young Jamie,
but you're actually all taught these
young folks,
hey,
calm down.
How old are you?
Uh,
34 that's old to these yarn.
Trust.
Anybody over 30?
It wasn't that the line.
Yeah,
that was back in the day.
Right,
but the 30s,
forties,
the new 30 so you know,
everything changes.
So what the fuck am I dirt like dirt
still at the top of the of the iceberg
though,
doing the ahead of the game and
everybody,
this whole thing,
what we're experiencing now I think is
the top of the iceberg because I think
there's some shit that's coming down the
pipe that is going to blow all this out
of the water and the idea of just
listening to things,
it's going to be ridiculous.
It's going to be so surface.
I really believe like what you were
saying about some sort of a matrix
plugin.
You can,
my friend,
my friend Dunkin has one of those htc
vives.
If you've ever seen those,
those you mean virtual reality?
Yeah.
You put the helmet on.
I have one.
You have one of those as well.
Part of the part of the Gig I'm working
on.
Yeah.
Oh,
you want to talk about it?
They sent it to me.
They sent it to me and I'll tell you
what's cool.
I didn't want to interrupt your story.
You go have been a change as well.
Google earth is on the the virtual
reality thing,
right,
and they just,
and they just started,
they just put out a new,
I think it's a new update.
Don't go.
I'm old so don't quote me on this,
but,
but the update allows you now to zoom in
at the ground level now.
It's not virtual reality at the ground
level.
It's more like your in the photograph,
but it's really cool.
I I,
it was just a week ago I went to all the
homes I grew up in as a kid and went
back to Jamie's.
Yeah.
He said,
this is how it always looked,
even like a year ago,
but now you can zoom into the ground and
there's people around you at all these,
it's truly awesome.
I have spent sane and it's only going to
be better.
They'll actually at some point have real
virtual reality on the ground.
Anywhere you want to go.
This is insane.
Well,
that's what I think is going to come up
next.
I think we're going to have it set up
where like this podcast,
you'll be able to put on some goggles
like this lady is wearing here.
You're gonna be able to put up some
goggles.
You're going to be in this room with us.
You'll be behind me.
You'll be staring at my butt.
You'll do whatever the fuck you want.
You'd be in the room.
You know what I'm saying?
You will.
You will be like a Sim game,
but you're in it.
That's common,
man.
This is,
this whole thing is going to feel so two
d and flat and archaic and just a decade
or so.
Everybody's waiting though for the big
seat.
It's funny how you wait for,
you know it.
It's,
you know how technology is adopted,
right?
You don't buy the computer just to have
the computer,
some new game or some new new ability
comes you,
oh,
I got to do that.
Well,
I guess I need a computer for that.
Everybody's waiting for that and the
virtual reality room to what's,
what's the must have thing that then
next Christmas everybody's got to have
the virtual reality set up under the
tree for,
you know.
Well I think one of the things that
setting android ahead of the curve in
terms of like android versus apple as
these android phones,
they slide into these headsets now and
they act as virtual reality screen.
Like a low level one.
Yeah.
Not that bad man.
No,
I haven't seen it,
but they,
you know,
they told me again,
they um,
that,
that the overlords,
yes,
the overlords.
I understand the mushroom overlords.
That's what I heard earlier.
Um,
but,
but uh,
but no,
they were telling me that,
that the I phones from apple also are
built for that capability.
They just haven't introduced the add ons
that you would need.
But in terms of the power that they've
put in there,
they built it for that so it can scale
up.
Eventually.
He just pulled it going to be talking
out of my rear.
Right.
You got it right there.
Apple reportedly readying standalone Ar,
which is augmented reality headset for
2019 well,
hey fuck face,
that's a year and a half away from now.
You fucking assholes.
When is this going to hit you?
That's what no one knows.
And everybody's afraid to put money
forward and not and be too early.
Like you were just talking about.
Hold on.
Look at this.
The device would run r o s apples,
reality operating system.
See,
that's the fucking Matrix,
man.
This is what everybody was worried about
with google,
that Google was skynet.
Google has your email,
google.
Some people were using google voice.
People use Google maps.
You,
I mean there's,
there's so much now that you're
connected to with this one company.
If they come out with some crazy
augmented reality thing and then you
like tap into that as well,
but everybody wants you in their
environment,
right?
Or I want you in the closed environment
so that,
I mean,
it's funny how the old aol model is,
is similar now to what they still,
facebook never wants you to have to
leave facebook.
Google wants you to be googled all the
time.
I mean old,
they keep me with the imessage.
I tried switching over to a Google Pixel
about a year ago for two days.
It was so bad,
like trying to get people to message me
like I would text people.
Did you get it?
No.
Send me a text.
I didn't get it.
Fuck.
And that'd be calling them back.
Did you send it?
Yeah,
I didn't get it.
It says it's centered.
Okay,
hold on.
I'm gonna send you one tone.
You get it.
He didn't get it.
Did you get it?
No.
Fuck.
So what do you got to do?
So then I go online.
You have to go to the apple.
I messaged servers and have your email
removed.
Okay,
I'll go and do that.
Nothing.
I was like,
fuck this.
And then I talk to people online like,
what's the best way to do this?
They go,
you gotta change your number or watts.
So if you want to try to use an android
phone,
you have to change your phone number.
I'm like,
all right,
fuck it.
I went right back to apple.
I was like,
I don't have time for this.
This is like,
this is too much noodling around high.
Now.
One problem with a password these days
can occupy your whole day trying to
figure out the problem.
So I mean,
I had it with the email.
I,
I didn't know Yahoo Mail was down.
So I'm thinking it's my problem.
So I'm spending the whole day working on
it.
I'm changing passwords,
look,
find out.
At the end of the day,
no,
Yahoo was just down all those past
rigid,
you'd have to do any of that and it's
screwed up.
Everything that Yad before and I'm 51
that's what happens when you get old.
Well,
I got a Mac book and I got a phone call
in my book.
Yeah,
me too.
What is this bullshit?
I updated something and all of a sudden
my laptop started ringing and I'm like,
no,
no.
We're not doing this.
No,
I'm not doing this.
Ask my children.
I'm at the point now where I'm literally
asking my teenage children for help and
that to me is a sign right there.
It's the first sign that eventually
leads you into that home that they put
you in.
You know what I mean?
This is the first step towards my
children going,
oh my God,
my father.
You know what's bizarre man?
My kids,
they just figure shit out.
Like if you give a kid,
it's,
it's amazing how intuitive some of these
APP creators are.
Absolutely.
Because my eye,
my nine year old,
she started making these little movies.
She's got this little editing thing on
our ipad.
My 12 year old does it too.
So she's filming little scenes.
She splices them all together and then
she adds music and text to it.
And then she goes,
Daddy,
you want to see the movie?
I mean,
I went,
what the fuck are you doing?
Good.
And it's good,
weird.
You know what?
You know what though?
I mean,
from a creative standpoint,
it's so easy.
Um,
and,
and I tend to have a personality that
does this.
Any way to look at the negative
Dystopian,
Ya know,
things that can happen.
The big brother things,
which is totally the way I see the
world.
But,
um,
but my kids,
when I look at the creativity,
so in my family,
I come from a family of people who
worked in film.
And so when I was a kid,
I had a super eight camera.
I had the old editing setup dance
licensed by,
I used to make a little space videos and
I figured out you scratch the film with
a needle frame after frame and you can
make laser beams.
And so when I was a kid,
I did that.
So like you said,
my,
my daughter comes up,
it was only two weeks ago and she's,
she's taken all of her school plays that
she's done.
She's taken scenes out of them,
she's backed it with music and she's
turned it into like a movie promo that
you see at the beginning of the theater.
And I'm looking at this and I'm going,
this is so dang creative.
And it's made,
you know how hard it would have been for
her to get a super eight camera and the
editing device.
We,
I mean,
this,
this makes it available to all these
people.
And so theoretically,
if it doesn't go the Dan Carlin
dystopian blade runner way,
it could easily be like this and this is
how I used to sell the the amateur
content to the venture capitalists in
the nineties by saying it's going to be
a creativity revolution and Joe Rogan's
nine year old is already taking part in
it and you're not even sure how she did
it.
That's how we know we're have no idea.
I watched her do it.
Mike,
how are you doing this?
Who taught you how to do this?
Because I figured it out.
You figured it out.
You just figured it out because God,
he just put destiny into that.
My Blah blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
She's like,
you want to do one?
Let's do one.
Like you can do them fast and slow mo
and all these different little effects
he could put on it.
Do you remember the old days when you
have two vhs tapes to trying to do this
and you would press one on record and
the other one I'm planning you would
record from each other?
Yes.
And it worked about 50% of the time.
It was like the cuts were so obvious,
like the cuts and scenes,
it was never seamless.
There was always like this big fucking
digital fas in between the scenes aspect
of something that you and I were talking
about when we first started here.
So it's,
it's what the technology can do.
So like I'm straight,
if you're out there,
you're going to hear me talk about this.
Now,
this may be a personal one to one
conversation with someone in your
audience,
but somebody did something that is both
flattering and absolutely terrifying to
me recently.
Um,
they went and they said it took hundreds
of hours and they called a ton of my
shows and they made little clips of all
the things I said and then rearrange
them and created an absolutely new show
about politics.
Unfortunately with me.
And you cannot tell that they've cut
this thing 9,000
different times,
but it's my voice saying a whole show of
political stuff that I never said made
up.
He said,
the guy said it took him hundreds of
hours.
Oh,
he's crazy.
Yeah.
But you turn around and you go,
okay,
somebody is going to take a little tie.
And he had at the beginning,
this is not Dan Carlin really saying
this,
but some guys going to take like some
obscure weird segment,
put it on the Internet and I'm going to
be chasing,
you know that group going,
no,
it's not me.
That guy didn't,
well you don't even have to do that
anymore.
If it's just audio.
What they're doing now is you could take
40 hours of audio,
which obviously you and I both have way
more than that.
They take that 40 hours of audio and
they can essentially have you say
anything,
anything ever.
So is that going to get us out of,
this is the conversation we had.
So can you say to somebody when they
say,
I heard Dan Carlin said he's all for
child molesting all this clip.
Can you say,
hey,
that's not me.
And look there,
there's all this stuff out there.
I mean,
is it gonna?
Is that gonna get you out of trouble or
a CNN gonna run that story and you'll
never be able to whack a mole your way
out of once they understand that that
technology is available,
they're going to have to be at least
questioning the source of it.
But if they don't,
you just see the shit out of him,
but I don't think they're going to
jump on.
It's sort of like photo shopping.
I'm shopping.
Do you remember when Oscar de la Hoya
got caught wearing fish nets and high
heeled shoes with boxing gloves on?
He was coked up and he was hanging
around with some crazy rush and
strippers and he was having a good old
time and just thought it was fun to
dress up like a girl.
And you know,
I thought it was funny,
but he was very deeply embarrassed by
it.
Obviously he's Mexican,
so Latino boxing fans were not taken
very kindly to that.
So he just said,
look,
that shits fake.
It's been photoshop.
Perfect.
Yeah,
look at it.
There he is.
Look,
how do we know that's Oscar Dela.
He's having a good time.
He's wearing a wig and one of them and a
hat they were thinking about is the,
is the left hook to the liver that
Bernard Hopkins hit him with,
put him down on the deck and I think
about him beating up Julio,
Cesar Chavez where all the Mexicans were
mad at him.
[inaudible]
prime.
Is that the girl that he was with go
above that.
The,
the two pictures with him and the girl?
Yeah.
Is that the girl that turned to been
keep an eye on that bitch.
If you're going to get a lap dance,
she's going to tell people.
She was like,
guess I guess they uh,
she,
that's her right there.
I guess that looks,
Photoshop does look sort of photoshop
and I'm not gladly because it's his body
means always an athlete's body,
but he's wearing a skirt and look,
they were partying.
He's having a good fucking time.
We thought it was silly to play.
Dress up.
What the fuck you mean?
Look at the one in the upper right
though and he's bending over.
Look at that one.
That one's rough weight of it.
So could you see,
it almost seems to me that it's the
perfect cover cause now you could do
anything you wanted to.
I mean if it's,
if it's the Clinton years in office and
bill cleanse,
I can do anything you wanted to just hit
it's photoshop.
That's not me.
You kind of can,
but they can tell they can sorta towel.
If you have an expert look at it,
they can break it down sort of.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of the problem is all
you have to do is have a few people say
it's real and then a few people say it's
fake.
And the people that want it to be real.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
And how do you chase it down?
I mean you would constantly be one step
behind.
It's even this way.
Like I was talking about piracy earlier
and trying,
you know I have a,
I have these old line advisors who will
say things like,
you need to be charging for your new
shows and not and more money into it.
And I sit there and go,
our competition is piracy,
man.
I mean you got to make everything so
cheap and guilt amounts of that.
They don't want to go pirate your stuff.
They feel but,
but,
but the,
the,
the idea of um,
I'm forgetting where I told him,
I told you this was going to happen.
Didn't have any shopping your moments
now.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
well we had it with Obama's birth
certificate or something like that.
The Obama birth certificate was a real
issue because there was people that were
examining it and they say they were
going putting it through photoshop.
They go and look,
this is clearly fake.
Look,
here's the filters.
You can see how it's been added and
edited.
But then you had a bunch of people that
were actually photoshop experts say,
no,
no dip shit.
This is how photoshop breaks down
images.
It breaks them down into layers.
This isn't fake.
Like this is the actual image and this
is how photoshop process is.
Images.
And so,
but it didn't matter.
All it took was enough people to show
you the original photoshop image and
say,
look,
here's why when we put it in photoshop,
you see all these layers,
clearly it's fake and then they just
fucking run with it.
They just run with it on their online
forums and on there they got the little
twitter group of right wing people that
want to think that Obama's at Kenyan
Muslim who's a some sort of Manchurian
candidate and there was a lot of that
going on,
but when I talked to people like Red
Band who actually understands photoshop,
he,
he's like,
no,
this is what happens when you put an
image in photoshop.
It breaks it down into layers like it
shows you how this is how you would edit
something in photoshop.
I think the point you made earlier when
you started talking about that though is
the key one,
which is if you want to believe this,
here's your evidence and you're going to
ignore it and if you don't want to the
opposite.
I wrote a piece that never got published
in the late eighties called the death of
objective truth.
And I thought at the time that this was
because you couldn't have arguments
anymore because no one would accept your
source if you said,
okay,
the New York Times said this when I was
a kid.
That was the starting point.
Right.
Okay.
If the New York Times says this,
okay,
we both believe it,
now we can have a conversation about
what the New York Times says.
Um,
nowadays I can't have political
discussions with people anymore cause it
never gets past ground zero.
Right?
We start,
I make a premise,
you challenge the premise.
I bring in a piece of evidence.
You say,
I don't believe that evidence at all.
Here's the other evidence.
And Boom,
Jonah Goldberg,
who's a,
like a standard conservative columnist
wrote a piece a couple months ago where
he said,
I can't even have fun political
discussions anymore cause you never get
past the beginning of the talk,
right.
We disagree over over the fact that
isn't even what we're talking about.
Right.
Here's,
here's,
here's reality.
Now let's talk about it.
Wait a minute.
That's your reality.
That's not my area.
And so you can't even have the kind of
fun political discussions we had as kids
or teenagers because there's a basic
disagreement on what reality looks like
to different people.
Yeah.
Well there's these tribal agreeing
tribals the perfect.
Yeah.
We have a tribal agreement to support
the left.
And you saw that with Hillary Clinton.
There was so many people that were
defending Hillary Clinton and people
were calling me right wing people that I
know.
We're like,
what are you a right wing?
Or now I'm like,
no,
Hillary Clinton is a fucking liar.
Like it's really simple.
Look,
I'm not saying that I liked Donald
Trump,
I don't,
but I'm saying you can't just because
you don't like Donald Trump.
Ignore the fact that the Clinton
Foundation is Super Fucking Shady,
that Hillary Clinton is clearly a liar.
That they definitely did something with
the DNC to rig the primaries to keep
Bernie Sanders out.
And now you have Donna,
what is her name?
Donna Brazil.
Donna Brazil coming out about all this
stuff too.
And she's showing how it was all done
and how Clinton sort of hijack the
entire DNC during the campaign made
everybody dependent upon her campaign.
The whole thing is tribal because people
didn't,
they,
they wanted so badly to get Donald Trump
and make sure he wasn't in office,
that they were supporting someone who
didn't even support gay marriage until
2013 I mean,
she was a creepy person in so many
different
ways and still is,
but she represents their team so they
would had this blind allegiance in this
tribal loyalty towards the left.
I think that's a real problem.
It's a real problem we have in this
country where people just,
I'm a fucking dolphins fan.
It's dolphins to the death and they get
that way with the cubs and they get that
way with Democrats and they get that way
with Republicans and you're seeing it
right now.
You're seeing it right now with people
that have an inability to in any way say
anything negative about Donald Trump
because he's the president because he's
a Republican.
Well,
you're not living in reality.
There's some,
there's certain things,
there's certain,
there's certain things that we really
need to be concerned about.
Forget about politics.
What about the Environmental Protection
Agency standards?
What about what they're doing in Alaska
where they're trying to drill for
minerals and,
and,
and uh,
they have this,
a very important salmon river that
they're going to drill right next to and
they're passing this without any advice
from scientists.
They're just going straight to it to try
to make money and people are freaking
the fuck out about this kind of stuff.
And Republicans,
there's so many of them don't want to
say a peep.
They don't want to say a word about it
because he's their guy.
He's on their team and people are super
tribal about it.
You know,
this is part of the problem I've been
having with my political show is I feel,
and everybody thinks it's a trump
related thing,
but I think it's what you said.
I'm,
I'm having an issue trying to figure out
if my basic,
um,
if my basic understanding of how a
system like ours is supposed to work is
fundamentally flawed.
You know,
I always,
I always like to say that wisdom
requires a flexible mind,
but I gotta I gotta live that too,
right?
So if I'm seeing stuff that doesn't back
up my theory on how things are supposed
to work,
I feel like I have to sit back a little
bit and go,
okay,
what are we seeing here?
And you mentioned a bunch of fundamental
societal changes we're going through.
And we started talking with whether
we're talking about amateur content or
everybody being able to broadcast and
all that.
We didn't even mention the fact that our
broadcasts are international now,
so you're not just talking to Americans
anymore.
Um,
and it makes me start to wonder about
the basic idea of are we smart enough
and this,
this goes against all my principles.
So it's hard for me,
but are we smart enough and does our
modern society require us all to be more
intelligent or in touch or understanding
of the facts?
Then,
for example,
American voters 75 years ago had to be,
um,
I'm starting to see,
and again,
this isn't about trump.
It's about what you were talking about.
The fact that we're having discussions
over stuff that either isn't real or you
don't understand the issue,
but you have a very strong opinion one
way or the other about it or some talk
show host you trust,
told you this is the way it is.
So you're going to believe it.
Let's put it this way,
let's,
let's say we've always have had
uninformed or tribal voters because we
always have,
is there a tipping point where if you
have,
you know,
if it's changing 10% every decade that
you say,
okay,
we used to have 20% of people who really
didn't know what was going on.
Now we have 70% of people.
I mean I'm starting to look back and go,
if you can't have basic discussions
about reality,
can you do your job as an,
as a,
as a voter in this society?
Um,
and I don't know.
I'm backing up going cause I'm a
Jeffersonian guy.
So I believe,
you know,
in the,
in the old agricultural,
old Republican,
you know,
there's a bunch of ideas that go to
that.
Part of it is a real trust in the
people.
Okay.
I can't decide if,
if the trust I've always had in the
people was misplaced from the bay,
from the get go,
or if the challenges of this modern
society that we have and an entire
generation and generations behind them.
Let's be honest,
growing up in a world of 140 character
conversations and all these different
things,
if that doesn't fundamentally change us
in a way that you might say,
listen,
in the 50s we could handle our,
our voting responsibilities better than
now because the challenge is to human
beings now are greater.
I don't know,
and I don't have an answer,
which is why I'm sort of backing off and
kind of observing instead of yakking
about it for a change.
Well,
I mean it's simple.
I think it's important to talk about it
just because we were all trying to
figure it out together.
I think so.
And I think that's,
that's really what's going on here is
that collectively,
we've never really had a voice the way
we have now.
It's never been 320,
whatever it is,
million people that can just chime in.
And it's not even that.
I mean we have foreigners in Russian
bots.
Uh,
I mean,
this is crazy.
This is never happened.
You know,
in the old days.
Do you remember they used to,
it used to be considered like what your
CIA would do or something just to,
to broadcast Radio Free Europe over the
Iron Curtain.
Radio Free Europe is a joke.
Now we all talk to each other.
All the timing.
It's,
and then you say to yourself,
okay,
if the Russians are doing this to us,
aren't we doing this to the Russians
have hindsight.
It's 100%.
In other words,
the fake news that's going on.
There may be a bunch of governments and
corporations and everything,
you know,
they,
they used to say,
the best way to cover up your lie is to
just flood the system with more lies
because then everything's up in the air.
Right?
I mean,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
And just,
it flooded and,
and I feel like we're flooded now.
And so if you say to yourself,
are we more flooded than we were 75
years ago?
And if we are,
does that require more from the average
voter than we required 75 years ago?
And let's be honest,
the dirty little secret of the American
system is everyone who studies it knows
is that once upon a time this voting
franchise was actually in relatively few
hands and you had to,
I mean the old idea behind running a
farm,
I used to read this,
a left wing writer who said it was all a
part of,
they hated poor people,
so they didn't want it to,
I dunno,
I think it was more of a voting
requirement that said,
hey,
if you can run a farm,
you can't be too much of an idiot.
So that'll be our requirement.
Yet I have this much land.
I don't know,
but,
but you do feel like as democracies
taken over,
because we're really a republic,
but we've been moving more towards a
democracy for 200 some years.
If that happens and you turn it go
clean.
Now we have no qualifications because
how would you implement them?
Somebody would say this is racist or
classist or whatever,
but without any requirements.
Are we doing a ha,
I mean how many people who are voting
really understand what's going on?
Well,
what are those requirements like?
Think about it from telling you that the
20 year old kid in my neighborhood
bought a $7 million
house from Youtube.
This kid is obviously very wealthy and
but does he know what's going on?
Do you have to be smart or do you have
to be wealthy?
Like do you have to be a land owner?
Do you have to be a farmer?
Do you have to be a business owner?
He's essentially a business and you're
going to take you to design test sort of
grades the test.
Who,
who decides what the questions of an
informed voter,
you know,
would know would be,
I mean other right in the left going
agree in a parameter,
be like gerrymandering,
the Gerrymander,
the test,
and you know these people,
these 320 million people,
this new found responsibility of being
able to chime in and communicate.
They're used to just being able to talk
shit at the gas station they used to be.
They're not used to this being
permanent.
They're not used to this being political
arguments on twitter or crazy dude.
The crazy crazy I want you look at him
all the time.
The crazy,
they're fascinating though because I
think this is one step.
I think this is step one to this
augmented reality situation that we're
talking about.
I think what this represents is a,
a deeper and deeper connection that
we're going to have with each other.
And I think we're going to get past
language and we're going to get past
culture and some sort of a weird way,
and it might take a hundred years to do
this,
but I really believe it's going to be
some sort of a universal operating
system that allows us to exchange
thoughts in a,
in a,
in a way that everyone understands some
sort of a Rosetta stone for the human
mind.
Oh,
I love that.
I love that idea.
I really think it's possible.
The stone for the human mind.
I think it's possible because I think,
look,
the,
the new,
um,
uh,
Google Pixel has ear buds and these
earbuds translate languages in real
time.
Oh yeah.
So if you're in another country and
fascinating,
and someone's talking in Spanish,
you will hear the translation in English
in real time and you'll be able to
understand what they're saying.
So that's what Esperanto was supposed to
be once upon a time.
Right?
I'm going to be the common language and
we would all learn it and because we
would speak it,
there would be no more wars and no more
awful things.
They thought,
and this is,
this is a,
the digital Esperanto.
I forgot about that.
Well that's that.
That was,
well,
Esperanza has been around for longer
than this,
but I mean the big push came after the
first world war was over and the League
of nations was formed and they were
trying to figure out how do we never
have a world war again?
We'll have to understand each other
first of all.
And you know what,
if you could understand all the speeches
and all the demagogues and all these
other countries,
right?
Yeah,
that's a giant issue.
I mean,
the Tower of Babel is based on that.
Totally.
And that that is a real issue.
I can't read Korean.
I,
you know,
I don't know what they're saying.
I look at Russian language and I'm like,
does these cases are really craving?
Yeah,
it's all,
it's all problem because the lack of
communication is one of the things that
makes it easier for us to look at people
as the other.
Yes.
Yeah.
And listen,
that's,
that's the common problem because when
people look at these,
um,
regimes,
let's,
we'll,
we'll take the standard one that you'd
talk about the Nazis,
but there's a bazillion regimes like
that.
The first thing you do is you have to
dehumanize the people you want to go
after because obviously we have human
feeling towards each other.
But if you can say something,
and I think this is what's been most
depressing for me is that we seem to be
backsliding on how we see people.
Um,
but I mean this idea that,
well,
for example,
one of the things I see all the time,
all the time,
and I don't know where it comes from on
twitter and everywhere else is this idea
that a,
that the different races are inferior to
white folks because white folks built
all of this and therefore we must,
and you turn around and go,
okay,
one,
how is that helpful too?
Is that even true?
Three.
So what,
so I mean,
the,
so what part is where you just go,
okay.
Are you doing anybody any good with
this?
I mean,
what,
what are we at?
And,
and truthfully,
I don't think most human beings think
like this.
We're trying to make a living.
We're trying to get by.
We try to get a date.
We're trying to,
you know,
I mean,
there's a bazillion things you have to
do in this life.
The idea that you have to be responsible
for,
uh,
pushing back racism in America seems a
heck of a lot of responsibility to put
on an average joe or Jane.
Well,
I think that these conversations are
very,
very important and I think we're having
them more so than ever before and these
conversations show how ridiculous it is
to have blind allegiance towards people
that have the same amount of melanin as
you do.
It's so fucking stupid.
All human beings essentially either came
from,
actually is some speculation that some
of them might have come from Europe,
uh,
thousands of years,
ago as well.
But we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of years ago.
The very first homo sapiens,
they believe came from Africa.
Everybody migrated out of there and
moved wrong.
We essentially came from the same
source.
So all of this idea of race is just
based on a particular amount of time in
a particular climate that forced people
to adapt to that climate.
And the colder,
darker climates,
you see Paler skin in the Sunnier hotter
climates.
You see more Melanin in the idea that
these people that live with have more
pale skin are superior than the people
that have more.
Melanin is just patently stupid.
It's just,
it's a dumb idea.
If you take into account all the socio
economic factors that cause people to
live certain ways as people that are
isolated,
that live in certain tribal traditions,
that these things are all easily
explained.
And if you want to chalk it off to
intelligence or the superiority of the
white race in 2017,
you're a fucking moron.
And this is,
uh,
it's a good thing that we can have these
conversations.
So you can expose these all these
Charlottesville people that you see
walking around with fucking swastika
tattoos like Jesus Christ.
You fucking dummies.
Those people that were involved in that,
those riots and all that racial bullshit
that just went on.
These people,
they need to see the reaction that the
rest of the world has and they are
isolated and insulated in their weird
little worlds and when they go global
with that shit and they march with those
Tiki torches down this tree and people
mock them and talk shit about them
openly online,
they get to understand how the rest of
the world sees this ridiculous ideology
that they subscribed to.
This is the power of of free expression
and communication that we're
experiencing in 2017 and this is the
power to nip a lot of this shit in the
bud.
If we can get past this tribal that
we're all taking part of this truck
we're doing,
there's tribal nonsense that's male
versus female.
There's tribal nonsense.
It's white versus black,
but there's tribal nonsense that's left
versus right.
There's nationalism does all this tribal
stupidity and all of this stuff is,
is being debated and exposed and it's
happening in real time and to you and I
can't happen quick enough.
It's still still too goddamn slow.
It's still too frustrating to the idea
that it's still around.
It's still mind boggling.
This kind of racism,
this open,
blatant racism still exists in 2017 but
it's way less prevalent than it was a
thousand years ago.
It's way less accepted than it was 2000
years ago.
And I think that's a blip in time as you
know,
probably better than anybody that I
know.
Yeah.
But you know,
it's funny because there's a part of me
that thinks that there must be something
deeply embedded in the DNA or our code
or whatever that that because it's
either that or people run into this
stuff and it appeals to them.
So let's say,
you know,
the first time you ever hear a speaker,
and look,
let me,
let me draw a distinction.
Because when we took,
I'm one of those people that actually
buys into the idea of,
you know,
I'd love to get to a place where we
judge people by the content of their
character,
not the color of their skin,
but let's not pretend that it's only the
white supremacist types that do that.
No,
we are so hung up on race that if you
could say something like,
uh,
in 15 years we are going to be a society
that doesn't even notice race.
Well in 1968 folks like Martin Luther
King might have thought that that was a
great thing today.
A lot of people would be like,
no,
wait,
wait.
We should still be noticing race for all
the,
you know,
these people need help.
Or the,
I guess what I'm saying is,
is that there's a pendulum and,
and I'm,
I'm looking at this,
I feel like we're right in the middle of
this right now.
So it's so hard to analyze it.
So everybody take this with a grain of
salt,
but,
but I,
I wonder if there's not a pendulum
involved.
So for example,
I tend to buy into most of the theories,
for example,
about racism that have always been put
out there.
But I think some are less helpful than
others.
And I think they all give you an
example.
And I think they come from academia
because I think this is sort of what
academics do.
And I,
and I think that that's their job,
but a lot of times they'll come up with
theories.
So one of the ones that,
that drives me crazy is white privilege.
Okay.
White privilege is true in the sense
that,
uh,
like,
like one African American guy said to
me,
he said,
I would love to forget about race,
but white people won't let me.
Right.
Which is an,
he says,
every morning I wake up and reminded,
and you don't have to deal with that.
I get that.
And I,
and I approve and I understand it,
but here's my problem.
You have to be able to see how telling
somebody that you were born with
something that you didn't earn is going
to be received on the other side,
right.
There are some people that have become
these white supremacists types or or
anti racial group because they're so
upset about their perceived position.
Right?
Like somehow you're blaming me for stuff
that happened to now.
True or not.
It doesn't.
What I always tell people is it doesn't
matter what's true or not.
It matters how that person reacts and
if,
if you're explaining to them that,
listen,
you born with all these unearned
privileges and their reaction is,
I'm starving here.
I don't have a job.
I'm living in a crappy,
how can you tell me that?
Then it might prompt,
and again I'm analyzing from within the
Maelstrom that we're in now,
but that that might be a reaction
counter reaction thing to say that we
could have a society where you judge
people on the content of their
character,
not the color of their skin.
That might be as upsetting for an
African American activist as a white
supremacist because this society right
now pays really close attention to your
race for all kinds of reasons.
I mean,
I'm one of those people that believes
we're all going to be a nice 10 color
someday,
you know?
And so it's a moot point.
But there are people out there who
literally think it's life or death.
If we do become a Tan people at one
point,
right?
We have to preserve this race or this.
I don't get any of that.
None of that makes sense.
That seems foolish.
But it's,
it's very,
it's consistent with the way human
beings evolved.
Trying to listen to the perfect,
her short lived in these small groups of
people.
We looked like each other and when we
saw these blond hair dudes pull up in
boats with battle ax as you're like,
oh shit,
they don't even look like us.
Fuck,
we gotta get Outta here.
That's literally what you had to worry
about.
I mean,
you had to worry about someone who was
the other.
Well,
and again,
we forget in this time and place that
the other didn't happen to be a skin
color thing.
I mean you could be the shark,
the Carolingian Empire that's being
attacked by the Vike Vikings and to an
outside observer,
you all look like a bunch of blonde
haired blue eyed guys.
But to them the vikings are the other
and in a tribal sense there is inferior
and awful and barbaric as anything you
can think of.
So we make the distinction now based on
this or that visual thing.
But throughout history,
like you said,
I mean you could go to China and they
have all sorts of different peoples in
China that they recognize as the other,
but if you're looking at them,
they all looked Chinese to you.
Well,
here's a perfect example where we have a
blind spot of,
this was in Iraq when we took over and
killed Saddam Hussein and overthrew him
and then the Sunni's and the Shias went
into a full scale and the Kurds and the
current,
everybody's like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is going on?
I thought you guys were all Muslim.
So many people had no idea there was two
competing sects of Muslims that lived in
that area.
They have no idea.
There was no struggle.
We may be talking about the population
as a whole but but come on,
the people in the government understood
this really well.
I mean this is why the first George Bush
didn't want to go in and and to topple
Saddam Hussein directly the way the
second Gulf War did because he didn't
want to own that mass and we knew that
those groups were there because we were
encouraging them and funding them to
overthrow.
I mean we,
there was a big Sunni Shiite rebellion
against Saddam at one point after the
first Gulf War,
which we were funding and hoping for.
The Kurds have been for a long time.
Our friends and we've been pushing for
something.
They're less than a state,
but more than what
they had under Saddam cause the Turks
don't love him and not well,
whenever you overthrow a dictator,
you leave a power vacuum and that power
vacuum is never filled in a nice and
calm and democratic way.
I mean,
look what's going on in Libya.
Libya is now a failed state and it is a,
uh,
like a breeding ground for Isis.
And it's be,
the reason why is because you had this
tie radical dictator and we had him
killed.
We had Kadafi killed,
which is another great piece of evidence
I used to point to with people with
Hillary Clinton.
Like,
watch the interview where she is about
to be interviewed.
She's still on camera,
but they,
they're not,
it's not any of you hasn't officially
started and she's talking about the
death of Kadafi and she's laughing.
She's like,
we came,
we saw he died.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And she's laughing.
This is not the kind of cavalier mindset
you ever want to see in someone that
possesses the power to overthrow a
government and someone who possesses the
power to wield nuclear weapons.
This is a person who's a chicken hawk.
You're completely shielded from the idea
of actually engaging in v actual
visceral combat yourself.
You're,
you're outside in,
in flying around in jets,
having catered food.
You're in war rooms making decisions
while you're an air conditioned
buildings.
It's all bullshit.
And these,
these decisions that you make have
massive repercussions for decades,
if not centuries,
centuries.
Here's the thing that you talked about
that I think is incredibly important in
the wrath of the cons.
When gingiss con took over Baghdad,
Baghdad essentially was knocked into the
fucking stone age and might not have
ever recovered.
That's true.
[inaudible] he just,
the Mongols destroyed the irrigation
system that had been around from time in
memorial and wood and how complicated
and and advanced their civilization was
at the time when the Mongols showed up
and did all this,
how few people knew this.
I think the,
the,
the question of asking about dictators
is really important because I think
sometimes you have to ask how much of
the fact that the country is held
together is only because there's a
dictator.
So we'll use the Yugoslavia example
cause it's pretty classic.
Um,
for those who don't know,
Yugoslavia is,
it was a country made up of a bunch of
different independent countries now and
they didn't necessarily get along.
As a matter of fact,
it's some of the oldest ethnic hatreds
in Europe.
When you talk about Serbs and Croats and
coastal vars and Bosnian Muslims and
Albanians and all the people in that
area there historically at odds,
but under certain governments,
a Tito,
uh,
after the second world war formed a
government where he essentially ruled
with an iron fist.
But that's how you kept all these people
from killing each other.
So when you say Iraq is not even a real
country,
because if you didn't have an iron fist
to dictator holding it together,
it wouldn't be together.
Right?
So then when you take the one lynch pin
as awful and Saddam Hussein was awful,
awful,
I'll give you a book read that will
just,
you'll have to,
it's the only book I've ever read that I
had to read another book afterwards
before I went to bed at night cause it
was so horrible.
Wow.
He's evil.
It's a,
it's called the great war for
civilization by Robert Fisk.
But he,
he's in reporter on the scene and he
would tell you what,
what is scrawled on the walls and the
prisons that Saddam Hussein's prisons at
the,
the prisoners would write in their own
bloody,
it's horrible stuff.
But the point is,
is that if there hadn't been a regime
like that,
would you have even had in Iraq?
So if you say to yourself,
okay,
this guy is the only reason this country
is held together,
what if you pull out that linchpin,
right?
And he'd say,
he's horrible.
Yes.
But if you could look into the crystal
ball and find out,
yes,
but we're going to lose a million people
in warfare between all these people.
If you pull the Saddam Hussein character
out of there too quickly,
it's like a giant Jenga game.
And if you put in the wrong piece,
and that's what happened,
right?
And it's still happening.
It's still happening.
Listen to Iran is the next,
I mean,
they're,
they're really gunning for lack of a
better word for Iran.
Um,
and you can see it if you,
if you know how to read the news and you
connect this dot with that dot.
It doesn't provide a clear picture,
but he say they demean the United States
military,
the United States government and our
friends.
And why are they gunning after Iran?
Iran has been on our,
on our net.
Naughty boy listens.
1979 they used to be our best friend in
the region,
uh,
even even better than Israel early on
because the Israeli relationship really
got tight after like 73,
74 but Iran,
we overthrew a government there with the
British.
Kermit Roosevelt was one of the people
involved in that and overthrew a
democratically elected regime under Dr
Mohammed Moza Deck,
put the shaw back in,
power his son.
And that became our little,
you know,
we had,
if you look at geopolitics,
it's all sort of like playing a risk
game,
you know,
and you want to have a little territory
on this side of the,
of the,
of the continent and then another one on
this side and that places.
So if you have Turkey as a friend and
you have a Israel as a friend,
then on the other side you have Iran as
a friend.
I mean,
we had this whole area sussed for awhile
and the 1979 revolution screwed
everything up and you could make a
decent case that it's since 1979 that
all this crap that we're dealing with
today,
including modern terrorism directed at
us stems from all that.
I mean,
that's the domino that begins tumbling,
that explains a lot of things,
including the 82 83 Lebanon involvement
and all that stuff.
Yeah.
It just seems like such a colobus mess
when you look at all the potential
pieces that are in place that could
cause chaos.
It's money though,
Dude.
It's money.
I mean there's so much.
You know,
I went to it,
I've said this before and it's like a
violation probably of my,
uh,
of what I said I would do.
But I've been,
I went to a Centcom meeting,
I was invited to this weird symptom,
um,
US Central Command.
I thought I'll tell you the story of
what time cause it was,
I thought they were going to kill me
that there was an assassination attempt
and you know,
I'm not a conspiracy nut,
but the whole story was really funny.
But long story short,
I ended up at this Central Command
planning meeting with 11 guys.
It's me and 11 other guys and generals
mean it was chaired by the guy who is
the defense secretary now.
Madis um,
so we sat there and they started talking
about half of it was,
well,
what do you think we ought to do about
this,
that or the other thing.
And the second half blew my mind because
the whole second half of the meeting was
about procurement,
not procurement.
Sounds boring when it basically means is
buying stuff,
military stuff.
And the meeting was kind of about how
important it was that that countries
don't start shifting over from say our
tanks to another country's tanks.
And it wasn't because we wanted to sell
them tanks,
it was because we wanted to sell them
spare parts for the tanks.
It's the old printer model,
right?
Oh,
we'll give you the foreign aid.
Sure.
We'll give you a lot.
We're going to defend you.
I'll send all this stuff free.
Yeah,
but then who do you have to call for the
spare parts,
right?
If you're using US jets,
well,
who's making the parts for those that,
who's selling them?
So when you sit there and realize how
much money is involved,
you're doubling down in a place like the
Middle East,
right?
You're doubling down because one,
you want to get the oil or you want to
have,
you want to,
you want to negate what's called,
um,
used to be called petro extortion.
Petro Black Male.
Because in the 70s,
and you and I are old enough to remember
this,
when you had the long gas lines and all
when OPEC punished countries like the
United States for supporting Israel,
the first thing you realize when
somebody can do that to you as,
oh my God,
job number one has to be,
make sure no one can ever do that again.
You can't,
you can't control our foreign policy by
saying you'll cut off the oil.
Because if you do that,
we'll just come and take the oil,
right?
We'll make sure you can't shut down the
western world because you don't like our
policies.
Okay,
I understand that a bit.
But then you say,
okay,
not only are we in there for the oil,
but these countries that are our friends
in the region who help,
who helped keep open access to the oil.
These are places that should be using US
equipment.
And if they're using US equipment,
we can sell them us spare parts.
So you're,
you're not only keeping the oil access,
which is important to us,
but you're also keeping the one industry
in this country we still made make a ton
of money in,
which is we still sell great military
equipment and great military parts and
we send our advisers and our maintenance
crews in every place all over the world
to to keep that stuff in running
operation.
That's doubling down.
So you get the oil and you get the spare
parts that you give away to them to
protect the oil.
So you're in this meeting with these
people.
How,
how'd you get,
okay,
well I'll tell the story because it's a
fun story,
but it goes so,
so we get,
you know how it is,
we get emails,
we get an email one day and we get a
letter to our mailbox.
The letter looks like some of what were
you doing at the time?
Just the podcast.
Just you know what we do.
And so they just said,
hey,
come on down.
We want to kill you.
No,
no.
It looked,
it looked like tell you about some shit
you should know about.
Well,
okay.
It even goes deeper.
I used to have a discussion board online
and some dude came on the discussion
board and was saying he was this giant
hacker,
this famous hacker.
You would all know me if I told you and
you know the discussion boards said
you're an idiot.
You know,
you don't know.
and the guy left the discussion board
saying,
I'm going to show you what I can do.
You won't believe you just keep your
eyes open for a couple of days.
You'll see what I can do.
So three days letter this letter.
Three days later,
this letter arrives in our mailbox.
The same day I'd get an email saying,
we'd love to have you come over to
central command and blah,
blah,
blah.
It looked like my daughter did it on her
printer.
There was no like,
you know,
government seals.
It didn't look official at all and it
was in,
I'm going,
okay,
this is this hacker dude.
This is what he was going to do.
So,
so it says it's got a phone number to
call.
So I called the phone number and it
doesn't even ring once and a machine
picks it up and just leave a message at
the beep.
I'm going,
what the hand telling my wife,
what the hell is this?
So I leave a message at the beep,
I hardly put the receiver down.
Boom rings and somebody on the other
line and it's a guy with a German
accent.
I'm going,
what the hell?
It's like some weird bad movie,
right?
And he goes,
no,
no.
This is all legit.
Don't worry.
You just show up at the airport.
There'll be a ticket waiting for you.
You take it to Washington DC,
there'll be a car waiting for you.
And I looked at my wife and I said,
but this hackers just going to take a
photo of me at the airport,
standing there like an idiot and then
put it on the website.
She says,
just go to the airport when there's no
ticket.
We'll know it's a scam.
So I go to the airport does,
it's so crazy.
I wish I was talking.
Okay.
So there's a ticket,
the ticket.
So now I've got my bag,
I guess I'm going to dc from Eugene,
Oregon.
So I get on the plane,
I get off the plane,
there's no car.
So I called my wife,
I said,
there's no car.
This is all a scam.
I don't know what this is a heck of a
lot of trouble to go through to scam me.
Right.
Okay.
So she gets a call from the German dude
in Florida.
He's at the wrong gate.
Go to this other gate.
So we go to this other gate.
A town car pulls up with a Middle
Eastern driver.
Yes.
Get in the car.
So I get in the car and then he starts
driving through like side streets in the
backwoods of Virginia or something.
So I'm on the phone when my wife go on,
if you never hear from him again,
I see a couple of landmarks here or
whatever.
He drops me off at this hotel in DC.
I still have,
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know why I walk up to the front
desk and I go to,
you have a reservation?
Oh yes,
Mr Carlin.
Hold on.
And they come back with this packet,
this and they headed to be there.
This is your homework for tomorrow
morning.
And I,
I go,
what?
I go up to the room,
I opened up this and it's all legit.
Long story short,
it's all,
and there's people at this meeting,
you're not allowed to say,
but there's people that if they sat next
to you would know exactly who they are.
And so I get to the meeting and it's,
it's all like Pentagon milk,
everything's confiscated at the door and
you get this military guy who walks with
you everywhere.
So if you have to go to the bathroom,
this dude has to walk to the bathroom
with you.
And so it's a table in this room and
madness is at the head of the table.
And then a bunch of soldiers standing in
a circle around the table just sort of
standing there.
So you've got like a cordon of soldiers.
And I'm sitting down there with all
these other people and I have no idea
why I'm there.
But,
so I opened up the packet and it's
everybody at the meeting and everybody's
got like three pages on their bio.
This the honorable Dododododo.
And then I opened it up and then there's
this little teeny piece of paper that
says Dan Carlin,
podcaster.
And they went to like Wikipedia,
which is all wrong anyway,
and printed it.
And I thought,
Oh yeah,
these August people at this meeting are
so excited to be at this meeting with
Dan Carlin podcaster.
Right?
So the meeting goes on for awhile and
then it breaks up in,
all these people know each other,
so they go off in their little corners
to start talking during the lunch break.
I don't know anyone.
I'm sitting at this table by myself and
this officer comes up and goes,
I bet you wonder why you're here.
I said,
yeah,
I really would love to know why I'm
here.
He goes,
that's my fault.
I'm the one.
He goes,
we listened to the show.
we're looking for out.
This was all about getting outside or
opinions on what you should do in the
Middle East,
and he goes,
it was my okay,
but here's the,
here's the other thing I was outside or
opinions on what you should do in the
Middle East.
Let's contact that guy does a history
pod,
but it's little fly him out to DC,
but here there's your tax dollars at
work.
Okay,
but it's,
it's,
it's a little bit more sneaky than that
because I was there with a guy who knows
how this all runs,
another guest and we took the taxi cab
to this place together and he's a real
cynical,
he goes,
let me tell you while you're here,
this is all a cover.
I go,
what do you mean it's a cover?
He goes,
it's a cover because these guys are
required by law to solicit outside
opinions for some of this stuff.
So that's what we're here we're going to
get.
And what they're going to say is they're
going to do exactly what they were going
to do anyway,
but there'll be able to say we solicit
to the outside opinion from all these
different people.
So I think that's what it was.
La Is it their radars?
Them,
I don't know.
But apparently they were supposed to
think outside the box and so they
invited and I was like,
I don't say mandated.
I don't know.
But I was the real outlier.
All these other people made sense.
I was the guy that was like,
okay they really getting crazy.
You wearing a suit or are you dressing
like that with a beach people wearing a
suit you wear was the last time I wore
one.
I,
it's funny cause they take this like
commemorative photo of you at the end
and then they say you can't show those
photos.
Anybody,
why are you taking it?
So I could show my wife.
Can you put it on the wall and your
house?
I don't know what's on the wall in my
house now.
So when you're standing there,
do you have like a badge on it?
So,
hi,
my name is Dan Carlin or it just says
Dan Carlin.
And then there's the dude who stands
behind you the whole time.
The military and say Dan Carlin.
Hardcore history.
What does it say?
I Dunno.
I'll show you.
It's on my phone.
I'll show you later.
Wow.
Um,
but,
but it was one of those get togethers
where you just,
I really wasn't as prepared as I should
have been because I was pretty darn sure
the whole thing was a hoax,
you know?
I mean,
first of all,
if you're going to send me a letter,
could it look like a letter that the u s
does it have to look like something
where you printed the label on your
brother label maker printer or
something?
They always want to leave.
Maybe they have multiple filters to
leave in the possibility of plausible
deniability.
And the German guy,
by the way,
what turned out to be like a west German
general that was,
was cooperating with the u s government
as part of an exchange program where we,
but I mean the whole thing seemed like,
I just thought it was this hacker dude
figuring out he's going to really
embarrass me in front of the whole
forum,
you know?
Oh Wow.
Dan Carlin at the airport thinking he's
going to Washington DC.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what I thought it was.
Some operation paperclip type shit
that's snuck him over there and dumped
them into Virginia swamp.
Wow,
that's fascinating man.
So did they solicit your opinions and
they talk to you about things that day?
All I can say is that both,
both Madison,
his,
um,
his aid,
which was Vice Admiral Harwood,
they are generals these days are so good
at pr because you,
you get this wonderful thank you note
where they go,
oh,
so great to have you.
Uh,
here's,
here's my,
please contact us if you,
and you're thinking,
I mean that's,
it's like a pr thing and I mean,
I do think there's a little bit of the
pr involved and I think,
you know,
has to be having the podcast or there
might have been good for pr.
Well,
for sure.
Maybe they thought it shut me up with my
criticism.
Right.
Bring you on in the inside.
You're one of our buddies know now you
have to be quiet.
Remember when Dennis Miller became with
George Bush
and you wouldn't make jokes about George
Bush anymore.
He's my friend.
I give him a pass.
Like what?
Yeah,
exactly.
What a fucking comic pal.
What are you doing?
Yeah,
it's um,
that's a fascinating thing that they
would bring you over there.
So you got to meet Madis.
He not only was he cool,
um,
but he,
he knows his history,
which,
you know,
I have a soft spot in heart,
but he was talking about,
you know,
we're talking about the Middle East and
he's talking about the history of this
and history of that.
And,
and I'm sitting here going,
and you know,
I know that history pretty well.
And I was sitting there going,
gee,
don't they call them the warrior monk?
I mean,
he said he was,
I found him fascinating I think.
And I thought he really understood what
I always hope these people understand,
which is the limits of power.
So you would say madison was very good
about saying,
listen,
we can't keep doing this and we can't
keep doing that.
And I thought to myself,
that's right.
I don't know how much the president's
listen,
but I mean I remember thinking Madison's
right about that.
So I think he is listening.
My friends that are in the military,
almost all of them universally,
we're very pleased that madness was
taking over.
He's popular especially.
Yeah,
he's popular.
Extremely popular because they feel like
they finally have support now.
They felt like they were handcuffed
during the Obama administration and that
there was this,
uh,
you know,
you had to go almost through a PR firm
before any decisions for me,
they had to like consult the
ramifications publicly is like that too.
They said,
Lyndon Johnson was picking the specific
bombing targets.
But,
but here's the problem you have.
Um,
if you realize,
and if you don't,
you're an idiot,
that you will actually hurt your
longterm goals.
If,
for example,
you hit a school and killed 200 little
children,
you realize,
listen,
the whole policy has really held hostage
by the potential for a disastrous
mistake because if the goal is to win
hearts and minds and listen,
you're not going to,
that's the only way to win this kind of
thing.
Um,
then you do damage to the goal with a
mistake.
And mistakes in war are inevitable.
So everybody I think is just trying to
be really careful,
but it's hard to fight a war really
carefully.
And this war is particularly weird when
it comes to that because of the use of
drones.
The use of drones has changed the entire
idea of what war is.
Because if you look at what happened
during the Obama administration,
this is one of the things that people
don't like to talk about their
supporters of Obama.
I believe the number is higher than 80%
of innocent civilians that were killed
by drones.
It's,
I think it's more than 80% imagine any
sort of technique and war or anything
else.
How about policing?
Let's just go for policing.
Imagine if there was some criminals that
were holed up in a building and you add
a hundred people in the building and 20
of them were criminals and you killed
everybody,
so you killed 80 people that were just
secretaries and plumbers and just folks
doing their job live in their life,
children,
their families.
You killed all those people to get to
those 20 people.
Everyone would freak the fuck out if you
did it physically yourself,
you ran in with a machine gun and gun,
everybody down.
You just,
I had to kill everybody.
That's the only way to get to the bad
guys.
Nobody would,
nobody would forgive you
and it would be front page news and it
would be a horrific crime,
but it happens constantly when it comes
to drone warfare in Yemen,
in parts of the world that we're not
even supposed to be at war with.
We're sending these flying robots,
they shoot something called Hell fire
missiles like Jesus Christ.
They're shooting Hellfire missiles at
these,
these targets that they're looking at us
screen and they're often in like the
midwest.
I mean that's where some of these
things,
you know what it is though.
It's all part of it.
Listen,
there's a,
there's a term and you military guys
listening will all know what it's
called,
Rma.
A real revolution in military affairs
and RMA periods in time happens.
So you imagine the period between no
gunpowder and the mass use of gunpowder
weapons.
That's an RMA period in history,
right?
But normally what appears to be fast,
like the transition from no gunpowder,
gunpowder is really relatively slow by
modern standards.
So you have several generations to get
used to the changes,
but the speed of the pace of change now
is so quickly that by the time you begin
to say,
okay,
we've been using the current weapons
systems and set up for five years,
now we think we're starting to
understand it.
It's obsolete.
Right?
What I said,
and this is so long ago that we've been
podcasting a long time Joe,
but I remember years and years ago when
we first started using these drones,
I said,
we're going to screw this up because
we're using them the same way the United
States used atomic weapons,
which is as though no one else will ever
get them,
right.
We are establishing the rules and when
other people get this stuff,
those are going to be the rules.
They operate under two.
But our attitude,
and I've never understood this,
but we have a very,
maybe it's the um,
maybe it's how democratic or republics
work in the sense that we can only
really think short term because the
politicians are only rewarded short
term.
But I mean if you say,
listen,
these are the goals of our drone program
for the next five years,
you're not incorporating what's going to
happen when China gets drones.
And if,
and what I said at the time is,
do you know how mad we're going to be if
another major country uses drones the
way we're using them now?
And it's the same thing with nuclear
weapons.
Once other countries got nuclear
weapons,
we backed off and went,
oh well then we have to have some rules
governing this now.
Well,
but when we were the only ones with
them,
we would threaten to use them all the
time.
Yeah.
You know,
you better not do that.
We'll Nuku easy to say when you're the
only ones with it.
So when you talk about the drone
warfare,
um,
I would suggest that the problem of,
of,
of collateral damage,
for lack of a better word,
um,
is when we've been dealing with for a
long time now.
I mean,
once you talk about the strategic
bombing of cities,
um,
first world war,
it started Second World War,
uh,
was massive.
Um,
then you,
then anything is a walk back.
So if you say something like,
yes,
Joe Rogan,
sure we killed those 200 kids at that
school.
And it's regrettable,
but that's an unusual thing.
It's not like world war two where we
carpet bombed whole cities.
Right?
And they're right.
But is that the standard we can operate
with?
Will,
I would suggest that the question is,
is does it hurt or help what you're
really after?
If,
if Joe Rogan's,
God,
sorry for even going here,
but if Joe Rogan's children were killed
in a bombing raid that another country
launched,
there is nothing that they could do to
stop Joe Rogan from hating them for the
rest of his life.
And if Joe Rogan hating the means,
Joe Rogan's going to find a way to make
you feel his pain.
You just created another enemy while you
were trying to eliminate enemies.
This is what's so scary about
terrorists.
You just changed not just the people
that were directly affected,
but the people that saw the ripples of
pain.
Giant.
Yes,
and again,
all I tell people and people get
offended,
Joe,
I've never understood people get
offended where I say,
just put yourself in the other guy's
moccasins for a minute,
right?
If you say,
because what people say to me is I had
some guy get screaming mad at me saying
basically he,
he followed the dominoes and saying,
are you saying we deserved nine 11 and I
said,
if that's really where you took that,
if that's where your argument goes,
I said,
then you totally misunderstood me.
I'm saying no one's saying deserved,
but saying this is probably what caused
it.
I listen.
Why are we a target?
It's not,
it's not wrong.
As a matter of fact,
I would suggest it is freedom.
What does that even mean?
And I would suggest this,
while there are some people who say,
listen,
look at the way you have women on
billboards,
scantily clad.
Yes,
there are people that hate that and that
they don't want that either.
At the same time,
in a lot of these countries,
you were talking about Iran earlier.
Let's talk about Iran.
Iran has got two separate things going.
They've got the countryside and they've
got the cities and they've got a ton of
the population that's under 30 and in
the cities they'd love to dance and they
loved,
you know,
the Iranians are not like the,
you said they all seem like Muslims to
us,
but they're all very different from each
other.
And,
and the Arabians,
for example,
are known to be kind of Spartan and
Stoic,
whereas the,
the Persians,
as they used to be called,
are a fun,
loving food,
loving dance,
loving.
I mean,
they're very capitalistic.
So in a funny way,
there's an,
and that's why we were so close to them
for so long.
There's a natural affinity between us
and I always say it would be pretty darn
easy if we treated them right the same
way my Stepdad said,
you know,
you can destroy the Soviet Union by
dumping Elvis records,
porn and blue jeans on them,
which kind of is what happened.
There's a way I think to approach this
Muslim world thing and let's not pretend
it won't be totally destabilizing
because if you drop porn,
blue jeans and Elvis on those countries,
now you're going to have a counter
reaction with all these clerics and
whatever that are freaking out.
But at the end of the game,
you won't end up looking like the bad
guy if you're bombing them.
It's,
it is so hard to look like the good guy
when you're bombing people,
you know?
And so if you could say to me,
listen Dan,
these are killers who want to hurt us
and we've got to take them out.
I totally get that.
But then I would say to you,
you have to take them out in a way that
doesn't screw up.
You know,
the main mission,
which is let's stop people from wanting
to kill us.
Right?
Like the way they took out Osama bin
Ladin.
Yeah,
that's about,
you know,
and listen,
what are some,
what that showed us too is that a lot of
these people that are supposedly our
friends in this war on terror aren't,
and we knew this has been the Pakistanis
especially,
but I mean they're not really that
close.
There'd be our friends because they want
the,
the spare parts for the tanks we gave
them and all these kinds of things.
So I mean,
yeah,
this global warfare things just,
you got to wonder at what point in time
is this ever gonna level is ever going
to normalize?
Is it ever going to calm down or what
does it get us?
What doesn't get us?
That's a song.
Well look,
I know what it gets some people there,
and this is the problem our whole
country has,
doesn't it?
That that some people are able to get
government to respond to them because
they give government money or what have
you,
and then they can get what they want.
But does that correspond to what we
need?
Right.
Do we need these wars?
I don't know.
I mean when they say we need to protect
the oil.
Well,
you know,
the whole oil climate has really changed
since the 19th just to protect the oil.
The idea is to keep these people at bay
so that none of them could ever
consolidate and become some gigantic,
huge war machine that could threaten us
globally.
You know what's at,
again,
this is a military history major
talking,
so I think differently about this,
but in a sense that would be so much
easier for us to beat.
I mean,
the funny thing is we know how to beat
big countries doing audit,
but if we're,
we're engaging in thermo nuclear
warfare,
nobody wins.
If we can stop them from ever getting to
that point,
that's the success.
The success is keeping them fragmented,
keeping them beaten down,
and that if we could do that,
we can keep them,
but they are showing that they can
destroy.
You know,
it's funny,
there's two kinds of destroy your
country.
There's destroy your country and leave
it in rubble,
which they can't do,
but there's destroy your country.
You know,
the old line is if they hate our
freedoms,
well they did a pretty good job limiting
them,
didn't they?
I mean,
because,
because we're eliminating them to
ourselves.
And I describes like fleas on a dog.
I mean,
they're like fleas on a dog and yet the
dog can tear himself to pieces trying to
get rid of those fleas and still not get
rid of the fleas.
Right.
Um,
but it's,
it,
you really,
I mean,
terrorism is so effective because it
requires people to act against human
nature,
which we can do as individuals,
but it's very tough to get us all
collectively to not act like human
beings.
It requires us to act against our
nature,
which is you punched me on punching you.
Right.
And in a funny way,
it requires us to be punched and to not
punch back,
I think.
But how does that work?
Right.
There's a,
there's a book by Mark Kurlansky who's
a,
who's a leftist for sure.
So just know going into it what you're
dealing with.
But it's a book on nonviolence and he's
trying to,
to point out something which I've always
tried to point out to nonviolence is a
tactic and against certain things,
it's extremely effective,
right?
It's not effective against everything,
but sometimes it's,
it's a fun,
I mean,
mark,
if you could do to Martin Luther King
what we could do to people now his,
his sitting,
uh,
for example,
one of the things you young people may
not know is one of the,
his effective protest was to go to these
all white,
um,
counters in the south where they
wouldn't serve black folks and just sit
at the counter and wait to be arrested.
And then when he was arrested,
Time magazine would be there to get,
and there's a great photograph of him
being handcuffed just for the audacity
of sitting at a soda counter.
Right?
And it was very powerful,
but it was powerful because you saw
violence initiated against somebody who
was totally peaceful,
right?
If today you could go up to him and just
tase him or do something that,
that that was not physically violent
than he wouldn't get what he needed out
of that,
which is he needed that photograph of
him being physically manhandled for the
simple or like not to change subjects,
it's the same subject but like the
pictures that were coming out when I was
a kid,
you can open up those giant life
magazine books with a great photos of
life and one of them was famous,
it was a black protester in the south of
Alabama or Mississippi and he's standing
there with his arms at his side,
not resisting at all.
And the police officer has,
has sicked a German shepard on him who
was biting him,
right?
And you look at yourself right there and
you go,
okay,
that photograph,
right.
They're motivated so much public opinion
in a different direction.
But what if they didn't need to use a
dog or a water cannon?
What if they could have just injected
you from behind?
The guy falls limping.
You just carry him off silently.
Will you just diminished his power to
make a deal?
Oh yeah.
That's it.
That's it right there.
And you look how powerful that is,
but it's powerful because some guy is
being violently attacked.
Two appears to be new.
Nothing more than asking,
uh,
you know,
for his rights.
Now,
if you didn't have that violence,
does that somehow change the message and
make it less powerful?
They could,
could've just injected him quietly,
taken him off to jail.
This doesn't happen,
and this made a big difference.
That's a very powerful photograph.
Well,
it's people who aren't there get a
chance to understand the barbaric nature
of this.
You get to see your,
you're literally getting attacked by an
animal that's on a leash and being
black.
I was going to say,
you would say,
well,
what did that guy do if he just murdered
somebody?
We're all going,
okay,
well that's what you get,
pal.
But if all he's doing is saying,
do I really have to sit at the back of
the bus in 1965 or something?
It this,
this kind of thing motivated a lot of
people.
But if you know it's like 60 minutes did
a great piece,
I want to say 1992,
1993 where they were showing all of the
new anti protestor weapons that were in
development.
And what's funny is several of them have
arrived.
One of them is the sonic cannon,
which they deployed against uh,
anti new world order protest or types
the,
isn't that what they used against people
that were in Cuba?
Wasn't that something,
I know there's a,
there's a rumor that there was something
used in people that hasn't been figured
out yet,
but this was the sonic canon thing where
you can target but something.
Got You.
Some people,
well some people said,
well,
Madsen,
Cuba,
right?
Yeah,
they will.
They said they lost their hearing or
something and they assume it was the
government that they were fucked up.
Like what the,
the,
they couldn't physically here it is that
what it was like something like that.
Just that's not hearing damage,
but see if he could pull that up and
figure out what the,
imagine instead of that power here photo
that made a difference.
Imagine if you could have just aim the
sonic cannon and,
and people leave because it's painful.
Well,
does that reduce the value then of that
nonviolent protest that was so powerful
and well,
this is what they're,
they're doing this right here.
This is,
this is really weird.
Um,
so a group of American diplomats in
Havana,
Cuba have suffered severe and
unexplained hearing loss over the past
year,
which u s officials believe was caused
by a covert and advanced sonic device.
So this is something that we're not even
aware of,
but we have those devices.
That's why they might know.
But do they just not want to comment on
that?
We possess these things.
He's able,
we know we've deployed them rip into
this one.
They don't know what this one is.
Right?
So they should know.
Anyway,
the device admitted a sound that was not
audible to human ears.
They added,
it would indicate that it was most
likely an infrasonic or ultrasonic
weapon.
Infrasonic weapons can cause physical
pain without detection though,
they usually target the entire body than
rather just the eardrums.
Wow.
How fucking bizarre.
That's like,
it's a different kind of origin bond out
control though,
you know?
And,
and if,
um,
you know,
for example,
the famous Gandhi Salt March,
which,
which is considered a,
one of the big moments in nonviolent
history where he had all of his
supporters walk into the clubs of the
authorities and he told them,
don't resist it all.
You just go down and then let the next
row get hit too.
And then the neck,
because that was a powerful sign of,
you know,
who's right and who's wrong in this
whole thing.
But if you could just deploy that Sonic
Canon and all those people had so much
pain in the rear,
they just had to leave and nobody got
beaten.
There was no blood,
there was no dogs,
there were no water cannons.
Does that undercut the power of
nonviolent protest to make change?
It's fascinating that that might have
been in the minds of the people who
designed this thing,
right?
Well,
it's so abstract,
the idea of this sonic weapon that you
don't hear,
but that affects your hearing and it
causes injury to your body,
but you don't hear it like the,
that's not going to affect us because it
doesn't,
it's not a bat,
right.
A bat that hits a person,
you understand it when you get a picture
afterwards that you can circulate.
Look what they did to me.
Well,
remember the Chicago convention in 68
that everybody,
you know,
where the protesters were beaten so
badly on television and all that stuff,
um,
if you didn't have to beat him,
does it lose a lot of its power?
If you just deployed the sonic cannon
and everybody goes away because it
hurts,
it seems to me like you would've just
diffused one of the most important
movement.
I would call that one of the big
political things that happened in the
United States in the past 50 years.
And if you didn't,
if there was no actual violence,
it's not a thing.
Isn't it fascinating that we have to see
something where we go,
oh,
I know what that is,
that's bad.
And then everybody gets outraged and
then then change happens.
Isn't that how the Arab spring stuff,
right.
That's the thing about drones,
right?
We're not there.
Right,
right.
The one of the reasons why you can
justify this is it's not actually done
by a human who's on the premises.
There was talk during the big bombing
campaigns at the Second World War when
they were talking about the morality.
This and Churchill famously saw the
movies showing some of these German
cities just leveled.
And he said,
are we beasts now?
This is the guy who ordered it.
Right?
But when he actually saw what happened,
well,
the guy I grew up next door,
um,
to was,
it was almost an astronaut,
but he was a fighter pilot.
And he,
but they conducted bombing runs in,
in Korea and Vietnam and stuff.
And he said to me,
if you actually had to see the people we
killed,
he goes,
we wouldn't have done this.
But you didn't have to see them.
There was,
there was a uh,
a distance and them,
and there's a book called on killing by
US army psychologist David Grossman's,
his name,
where he talks about killing in terms of
distance.
Everything is distance.
So there's intimacy range.
That's when you're killing somebody with
a knife close up and then the farther
away you get,
the easier it is to do the deed he says.
And the less you,
the less damage you have later
psychologic.
Isn't there an analogy to social media
here about people that can say maybe
we'll cruel shit to people,
it's actually on connection and they
can't do it in person,
in person,
it wouldn't,
it wouldn't even be in your character
doing a person that not even in your
case.
In other words,
you almost have like a dual character
that comes out when you know you don't,
you don't have to see this person.
And truthfully,
all I really want from Joe Rogan has to
answer to answer me in the best way.
He can answer me as if I call him
something,
you know?
Well anybody who does anything negative
where the public is aware of it.
Like,
say this Louis C.
Case thing or something like that,
or you can immediately find and target
that.
Now I have a reason to go after this
person.
There's a,
it's a,
it's an acceptable target.
It's an agreed upon target and then
people from all over the world could
just pour their vitriol and anger and
bitterness and whatever it is because
they have some sort of a righteous anger
that they could,
well there's a reason I can be angry at
this person or I saw what a Kathy
Griffin did when she held up that head
of Donald Trump.
But I have a reason now.
I mean I don't,
I'm not standing up for Kathy Griffin
cause I think what she did was stupid,
but she was just devastated by that.
I mean they went after her like death
threats and hate and anger.
Joe,
you've taught me a lot about the whole
social media thing though,
because I would come in here,
the audience doesn't know this,
but I would have questions about that
stuff.
And you've,
you've thought more about this than I
have and you were able on several of k I
quoted you where I,
you know,
I mean,
cause I tried to make sense of this
stuff and like I said,
you're farther along.
I think the road of thinking about some
of this stuff and it gave me some
shortcuts,
but I mean I do because I think it's a
fascinating phenomenon because it's
never been available.
And when did people ever have this kind
of power?
Your average guy locked in his basement,
you know,
never goes out,
but he could still talk to the world.
I mean that's the problem.
We have the stereotype of this loser in
their basement.
Which basement?
Good.
No,
it could be a guy with a family who's at
work.
Yeah.
And it was just his wife or his wife or
his kids.
Anybody just saying horrible shit.
I mean there's just,
there's so many options for people to be
nasty to each other.
And this absence of social cues,
absence of like being in the physical
presence of someone,
it's,
this is an alien way of communicating.
It's not normal.
It's one of the reasons why I always
hated the letters because people could
write some,
like I'd get letters from an ex
girlfriend.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
This is,
this is a bullshit depiction of our
relationship made this
romanticized idea of what this is all
about.
Like I don't like letters because
someone can't be there to go,
wait,
what?
That didn't happen.
Yeah it did.
No,
don't you remember you said this?
Oh yeah.
You know there's a physical proximity
question too.
Like you're not going to go up to this
guy and say this stuff to his face
because he might knock you in.
The head.
Can think about a letter is maybe if
someone is an honest person,
they can express themselves in a letter
in a way that they would have a
difficult time doing it in first and
then cause they full too and they feel
embarrassed or they have,
when you're writing something,
you have the opportunity to really think
about your words and edit and go over it
and then decide,
this actually represents my real
thoughts and as imperfect as it is,
send it.
But when you can do that any moment of
any day with your phone in the middle
like someone's talking to,
yeah,
hold on a second,
hold on a second.
Jump the fuck you fucking asshole.
And just tweet the top of these athletes
or celebrities getting with with what
was obviously I'm just about to board
the plane so I'll just and boom they get
off the plane and there's a huge
firestorm cause cause something was
taken wrong or not the way you meant it.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean it's a weird time and I think
this is,
I think we're at an adolescent stage of
communication.
That's what I think.
I think we went through all these
rudimentary steps,
right?
We went through grunts and then we had
verbal language and then we had written
language and then we had the printing
press and then we had the ability to
broadcast and then then we had social
media.
The ability for anybody to broadcast.
And I think as we move into augmented
reality and what I've been thinking
about more and more is this Rosetta
stone idea.
This idea that we're going to come up
with some sort of a way of communicating
ideas that's not limited and restricted
to language as a military history
fanatic.
Do you know what I instantly think of?
I instantly think of the fact that could
you start a war if one country's average
joes and Janes on social media or
whatever passes or start really
disagreeing in their thousands and tens
of thousands and 50 thousands with
people in another country.
And we could,
could the Russian people via social
media anger the American people via
social media to such a degree that
countries get pulled into conflict?
I don't even,
it's never been possible.
So you can't know.
Uh,
but,
but you turn around and go,
that would be an interesting,
that you,
you point out quite correctly that we're
essentially Guinea pigs here right now.
Yes.
Which is what I tried to explain to my
daughters that we are,
we are in an era where we're seeing what
happens when you hand humanity these
tools that they've never had before.
Uh,
and there's two ways of looking at it.
The optimistic one with this is going to
free up,
open up all or the pessimistic ones,
which say maybe something like,
Ken,
our representative democracy handled
this and not because we can't handle
communication,
but maybe like you would say the kind of
communication that we have where these
are little teeny chunk.
We're not having deep philosophical
coffee house Ben Franklin,
kind of calmer.
We're having 140
character discussions.
What can you say at 140 characters other
than you're an idiot.
You're wrong.
It's fake news,
you know in the story and where it to 80
now.
I'm sure that will make all the
difference in.
I wonder if it does.
I help me get clear my,
I can't clear my throat 140 characters,
so it'll help me.
I think it's going to cause a shift.
I really do.
I believe that the shift from one 40 to
two 80 will make people,
it'll give people the opportunity to be
more clear with their ideas.
I will say that it's disheartening for a
person like myself who enjoys depth
because even the history shows her so
long as I enjoy the depth to see people
confronted with like a page of text
going on too long to read it funny,
but you do go,
okay,
can you really be a useful citizen as a
voting member of this,
an informed citizenry and do your job if
if,
if you see a page of text like Whoa,
I mean the constitution today would have
to be 140 characters,
you know,
for,
for most of the people today to go,
okay,
I'll sit down and read that.
One of the things that your podcast has
done that's amazing has given people
information in a very entertaining form
that they would never sit down and read
a book about.
There's a ton of people,
probably me included that will never
read as much about Genghis Khan as I got
from your podcast.
But you went to see,
and this is what I hope for because we
always say I don't,
I liked the idea of being an appetizer
for people on history.
If I introduced somebody to the Hmong
goals and then they went and go to our
website,
we put all of the materials we use and
we linked directly to a place where you
can get them.
So if you actually went out and bought
some books on the Mongols after that or
or that created an intellectual
relationship between you and the Mongols
were for the rest of your life.
Oh this is a mongols they found Genghis
Khan's tomb or something.
You're into it because you know about,
well I mean that's awesome.
In terms of,
I mean I heard 'em,
I got a great letter,
this is the highlight of my career was
this letter from the wife of a historian
that we used in the world war one series
and she wrote me this letter saying you
have no,
this is like very self serving,
but you have no idea what you're doing
because history is something that not a
lot of people were getting interested
in.
And now we have people showing up in the
classrooms becoming history majors
because they got interested in what you
were doing.
So if we're poking people with a stick
and getting them interested in this
subject,
do you know how cool it would be to have
that?
You know,
when you're,
when you're all dead and gone and
somebody says,
what did you do?
He said,
wait,
he got a lot of people really interested
in history.
I think that's the coolest thing in the
world.
They've done that.
But it dovetails with what we were
talking about.
This whole new media.
Will it be good?
Would it be bad?
And it's probably going to be both,
right?
But the idea that people could get
interested in history again because some
idiot in his garage was talking about
it.
Uh,
I think could be everybody,
but it's going to be a lot of people and
for those people it is going to have a
profound effect and me included.
And I think that ha this new media,
this thing where nobody is telling you,
Hey dan,
it's time to do a podcast on blank.
It's time to,
you know,
cut back this edit that you're doing it
based on your interests.
Your knowledge wouldn't have been this
show if we'd had yet.
There was anybody else.
There wouldn't have been this show.
I would never been able to pull this
off.
Not in a hundred years.
It's what we have is this unique
opportunity to express ourselves in,
um,
uh,
like with a,
with a personal viewpoint.
Like this is,
uh,
your,
your personal interest,
the things that you're,
you,
there's a pure,
yeah,
it's the difference between blended
whiskey and like a single malt where,
where if like when I get these TV offers
and you've had zillions of them,
where you go and you talk to these
people and you realize instantly if I go
do this with them,
they're going to homogenize it,
dumb it down,
but they're going to check and you sit
there and go,
they're going to make something far
inferior to what I'm able to do myself
because they really don't understand why
it works in,
in other words,
like you said,
you couldn't have been able to do this
show.
It's funny to me that the industry,
for example,
doesn't realize what it is that people
like about what you do.
And figure out a way to,
you know,
they,
they're not open minded enough to say,
listen,
Joe come under this TV show,
which is a lot like what you do.
I don't,
I don't get it.
I don't understand how people like you
and people like me and all the people to
do what we do,
haven't created more of an understanding
in the old media.
I think they're getting it.
Do you think?
Well,
eventually there was no way to avoid it.
They're getting it now.
I see.
Like when I get offers for things,
I understand things like,
oh,
they're trying,
they're seeing what I'm doing.
And they're going,
hey,
we want a piece of this.
How do we,
and then,
but if you do a pan,
they pull it off.
I mean,
it would be the same thing.
This is the problem.
If they did this,
it's like say if say,
hey,
we want to put your podcast on blah,
blah,
Blah and network.
Okay,
well now I have a bunch of people that
I'm talking to that I have to run things
by.
Now I have Zach have a bunch of people
that say,
I just think that if you're dress nicer
and then,
oh,
Jesus,
okay,
well now,
now it's not me.
I'll tell you a story.
So,
so the,
so,
so finally,
the TV people,
um,
they're always promising things.
Well,
you can do it any way you want you so
far.
So finally,
one of these companies did it so many
times.
I said,
okay,
I'll go forward with you and we'll start
with this project.
Great.
So I'm in a particular us city in the
south and we're,
we're cutting the sizzle reel.
And I said,
now this is going to be hardcore,
right?
You got me.
You want hardcore history?
Yes,
we all the history channel.
Everybody wants it.
Okay.
So I said,
so here's what we're going to do.
So the,
the,
the sizzle reel was on the bombings in
the late sixties,
early seventies,
of like the new left.
So the weather underground and all those
people,
right?
So I'm going to do this.
And I said,
I said,
so the hardcore history way to do this
though is to imagine that era with
today's anti-terror laws and the way we
treat terrorists today.
So we were filming like recreation's of
like Abbie Hoffman and his American tee
shirt being waterboarded by CIA agents
because if we applied to the modern
anti-terror to the way that the
Americans and they out,
they said,
listen,
there's a lot of red southern states
that would not go for that and all these
guys and you wanted hardcore.
That's,
that's no,
they didn't really want hardcore.
They wanted to get me through the doors
and then we're going to make some group
think thing,
you know,
or the group or no effort in group think
creativity.
Well group think would be fine if you
respected all the think in the group,
think if they were all as good as you.
They don't have the sensibility that not
most of these people,
most of them were kids.
From my standpoint as an old man,
now they're all counters.
They're bean counters that are trying to
protect their own jobs.
What they're worried about is the
numbers.
We got the dailies in,
we've got the,
we got the numbers in your trending
really well in 18 to 34 Dan Carlin,
and it's not about building an audience
over the long haul.
Like you said,
it's literally about the next rating.
You've got to jump in out of the gate
big time and you have to have billboards
and a big push.
I'll give you notice anytime a show
launches,
you'll see bill bill board,
like there's this new show called white
famous and it's on showtime.
And everywhere you go,
this is giant billboards for white
famous.
They're not letting this thing build
slowly.
They want to push it out of the gate
with gunpowder,
boom.
And they're hoping that with that
momentum,
the quality of this show will add to the
momentum and then you're going to build
up and a bunch of people catch on and
eventually we'll get rolling.
But in order to do that,
they want to take away all the jagged
edges,
smooth everything down to make it
aerodynamic,
make everything like super homogenize.
I mean that's what they do with every
single city.
Oh.
And what they'll do to your career.
Like the last physical fight I almost
had with another adult male was a radio
program director.
And the radio program director came into
my town knew,
and you know,
if you've ever been in radio,
when they come into town,
knew the first thing they're going to do
is change everything cause they got to
put their own stamp on it or why are
they there?
So this guy comes in and he goes,
we're going to rebrand you.
He goes,
I want everyone to think of your name
and instantly think of the brand.
And I'm already,
you know Brian?
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's what he said.
So I hate to say this because this will
become a meme online that I will have to
live with the rest of my life.
But it's an absolutely true story.
So the guy says to me,
he goes,
listen,
uh,
imagine a billboard that says Dan
Carlin,
he fucks chickens.
And I said,
excuse me?
He goes,
yeah,
I mean,
so that anytime anybody thought,
if you,
they would think,
okay,
he used the chicken fucker and I'm
going,
wait a minute.
Really?
He really said yes,
and I said,
I said to him,
I said,
I said two things,
dude.
I said,
the first thing is I got to live in this
town,
right,
so really you want that to be the first
thing people think.
Okay.
The second thing is I got to have a
career after this stupid idea of yours
fails to understand where we're building
up a mental image.
You'll be a household name.
I said,
yes,
I'll be the household name.
The guy who fucks chickens.
I said,
and,
and finding,
you know,
he was.
After that,
I find these guys.
I said,
dude,
do you want to step outside right now?
I don't mean my wife laughed at me
because I'm already an old man.
When I'm saying,
she goes,
that would have been great.
I said,
no,
this,
this guy was as old as I was,
but I was so incensed and so angry that
this guy would,
would be so cavalier with your future
human being and every family,
I mean,
my kicker,
how are they going to spell fucker on
billboards?
You know what?
That's a really good credit they might
have had is a euphemism.
But I mean,
you think about that.
You think,
okay,
as you said,
this guy's career depends on him making
a difference.
I'm just a tool in his career,
right?
So you start to realize that when you
did the podcast and it's your podcast,
the person that you're worried about
here is you.
And not just that,
the ideas that are coming from your,
not just
yours alone,
but you own them.
Right?
So,
so when I say something that's stupid,
I own that.
It's not like some stations said,
oh,
it doesn't push.
You know,
I got to know fight over the Oj Simpson
thing when the Oj Simpson trials going
on and everybody,
it's all you hear anywhere.
So I didn't talk about it.
And so they got on me about not talking
about it and I had a big fight and I
walked into the studio and I said,
fine,
I'll talk about it.
I said,
you know,
the whole topic was,
isn't it just too much?
Damn Oj Simpson everywhere you go.
Oh they were.
They were.
They were at the,
you know,
there was a window.
We were like zoo creatures and they had
this window.
They could bring all the sales clients
to watch us perform and I'm doing there
and there's like five executives in the
window just waiting till the next
commercial break because we're going to
be,
we're going to,
but I mean that's why radio was so awful
for me and I didn't get fired.
I must have done a good enough job to
stay employed,
but it was go home and pull your hair.
[inaudible] intention.
Constant 10 imagine this is a good
example for people.
Imagine if you're a painting,
a picture.
You had an idea to paint the Mona Lisa
and you got a bunch of people standing
over your shoulder like,
hey,
make her no small.
Exactly right.
You know,
you get to,
her eyebrows are too bushy.
She looks to Italian and I'm like,
there's a bunch of fucking people.
If you're dealing with these things that
are just essentially trying to justify
their jobs,
I mean you're always having that
whenever you're,
you're dealing with any sort of an
executive position and one of the things
that you realize is how many people are
unnecessary.
I did Bill Simmons Show,
you know Bill Simmons had a successful
podcast and that podcast that led to an
hbo show and I had a great time on the
show.
No,
no,
I like him.
He's very nice guy,
very smart guy.
But when I did his show,
I'm like,
there's a hundred people working here.
It's fucking people everywhere.
I get that you need cameraman.
I get the need sound men,
but then who are all these other
fuckers?
You got all these executive type people
and office people and all these people
running around.
I'm like,
you've,
you've made this way too complicated.
Like the reason why his podcast is so
successful is because it's him.
It's his singular vision.
His idea,
you're,
you're getting it from this person and
when you know that you're getting
something from a person and you like how
that guy thinks,
then it becomes interesting.
But when you're not really getting it
from that person,
you've got a bunch of people holding cue
cards and standing behind them and
you're creating this bullshit thing.
Well,
my wife said today we're,
we're in the hotel room and she turns on
the TV and Ryan seacrest is on and he'd
liked,
does 10,000
things a day,
you know,
multiple shows.
And she says,
I don't know how he does that.
That's amazing that he can do all these
kinds of things.
I said,
how much of it's really Ryan seacrest's.
I mean how you,
you basically have to have everything
ready to go when you walk into a room
and who did that?
You know what I like listening to Ryan
seacrest.
I like listening to him on the radio
because it's almost like listening to an
alien that tries to be like a woman
who's a secretary because he does these
contests like cola call in right now and
like,
you know,
have someone to call him.
I like the nagging or whack and then I
can go to the bathroom and look at my
phone.
Hey,
everybody likes that.
All right,
let's neck and you're,
hey,
you want two tickets
to this art?
Congratulations.
All right,
Monica,
nice talking to you.
I was like,
he's not even a fucking human on those
things.
It's like he's figured out a way to hit
this wall,
this droning sound that resonates with
the people that live in that existence.
So the people that are stuck in traffic
and that checking their phone every 15
minutes,
those are the people that are on
instagram 35 times a day.
You know?
That's the average amount of time a
person looks at instagram 35 times a
day.
Wool wool,
Ryan seacrest fucks chickens,
dude.
Well,
if he fuck chickens,
he would be like outrageous.
Like that would be like that.
The guy who said,
you're going to be the chicken fucker.
He probably listened to Howard Stern.
He's like,
this guy is outrageous.
We need to get Dan Carlin to be
outrageous.
You're a chicken farmer.
Well,
I it,
that is the other thing with the
homogenization talked to,
it's always about imitating somebody
who's found a good formula.
I will say this about limbo.
Limbo is right when he says that there
will be a wing in the talk radio museum
devoted to him one day,
but,
but what he always says,
which I find interesting is he tried to
do what he does now multiple times and
got fired because their attitude was,
what is the way and we're not taking any
chances with this.
And then he says,
the minute I'm successful,
every consultant out there is telling
everybody to be as just like him.
In other words,
if you really,
and if you're a podcast are out there,
are thinking about doing something in
the new media,
understand that there is something so
valuable about what you specifically are
bringing to the table.
And the minute you ask these other
people what to do,
they're going to,
they don't know what specific about it.
They're going to go and say,
well,
we can pull a little piece of what this
person does and eventually it's not even
you.
One of the great things I always thought
about hardcore history is that over time
you self select your audience.
I think you do that with every podcast.
So you say something like,
okay,
I'm only going to talk about the stuff
I'm interested in.
Well what you know then a year later is
whatever fans are listening to you.
It's a pretty good gauge because they're
there because they like what you're,
so I don't have to sit there and go,
gosh,
this would be a popular topic.
I just do what I want to do.
And over time you developed an audience
that likes that.
I also think that there's something
happening when you do have this sing,
when you have a singular vision,
like one person who's,
who's driving this thing,
right?
And over time I feel like people get a
sense of you in a way deeper sense.
And just listening to your words,
they're chunking data,
they're adding up all of the
communication that you've had.
They're seeing how you add,
they're analyzing how you see different
scenarios.
They're analyzing how you,
how you navigate certain and they're
seeing you when you're tired and they're
seeing you the way you're feeling in a
great mood and then maybe they're seeing
you when something bad happened.
You don't feel so good.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
and all this is like,
so they get to know you and there's
very,
there they,
there,
there's an intimate understanding of you
that is almost impossible to get when
you're hosting the tonight show or
you're acting in a television show
or doing a five minute piece of content
opposed to a three hour piece of cotton.
Yeah.
There's a weird thing.
I think that's one
of the things,
like if people know me,
if you listen to his podcast long
enough,
you know me and you might not agree with
me and you might think I'm wrong or I'm
a blowhard,
but you know,
I'm honest.
Right.
Um,
this,
I might be wrong,
but I'll tell you if I think I'm wrong,
if I think I'm wrong,
I'm the first person go,
I think I'm wrong.
I'm,
I'm not.
I'm never going to cover that up.
And you shouldn't believe people that
don't think they're wrong.
You can't,
it's not good for you either.
The person who pulls it off,
it's not good for you because you know
you're wrong and you're know you're
carrying that shit around your head all
the time.
Though I always say,
if you think if people,
and this is again why,
why one of my current events,
podcasts is not really happening right
now because I,
I feel like when you're in absolutely
uncharted water,
you can't know what's going on.
So that's how you feel right now.
I think we're in uncharted and I think,
I think it's a combination.
Everyone,
everyone always thinks it's a trump
thing,
but to me,
trump is a vector.
A,
to me,
what you were talking about with the
social media is as much a part of,
of what makes this an absolutely
unprecedented time and a bunch of other
things.
The globalization of the earth.
Like you're saying,
I'm,
we're doing shows and hearing from
people from other countries,
I mean all this stuff interacting
together has created an absolutely
unprecedented situation.
So maybe I just organize my thinking
differently,
but I organize it historically and
there's no way to put this into any box
that's ever existed before.
So when I watched these talk shows or,
or whatever with people who have no
choice,
it's 6:00
PM I have to be on the air and I have to
have something to say to rile the
audience.
Um,
you know,
they have no options.
They have to,
their Gig is,
I know what's going on in,
let me tell you.
Whereas if they were honest with
themselves,
they either would have to say,
I don't know what's going on and I'm
watching too.
Or if they really do believe they know
what's going on,
well then you really shouldn't be
listened to them at all.
Right.
Then there is no way they could,
there's no way they could know.
Yeah.
I think we're dealing with the
ramifications of a bunch of different
pieces that are in play.
Yes.
And I think one of those pieces that
it's in play and one of the reasons why
you see so much bitterness and anger and
social media and you know,
we talked about this mechanism that
social media allows people to
communicate in this really cruel way
without experiencing that person right
in front of you.
Right.
But I think one of the reasons why these
people have this deep seated anger and
resentment is there's a bunch of people
out there that have these lives that are
deeply unsatisfying because I think
somehow or another through momentum and
just through just things falling into
place the way they are and people trying
to fit their lives around the way these
pieces have fallen into place,
there are so many people that are
working all day long doing something
that is deeply unsatisfying and,
and almost painful to them.
Yeah.
Soul killing,
soul killing.
They're stuck in traffic all day and
then they're stuck in a cubicle after
that.
They,
they,
they relish the time to take a shit in
the bathroom and look at their phone.
I mean,
they literally do that.
That's a highlight of someone's day.
They get in traffic on the way home.
They get home after that,
they're watching television and they're
fucked.
They have deep debt.
This is not like there's this soul
killing thing is not giving
them any three.
That's huge and you know what?
You just sit there and go in and you
look at what people make and you sit
there and go,
you can make quite a lot of money by
average Joe Standards and still not be
in good shape.
So I know people turn around and make
good living,
really good living and turn around and
go,
I'm just holding my head above water.
And so you go,
okay,
if you're holding your head just barely,
what's a person making a third or a
quarter of what you're making doing?
I mean,
this is really,
when you talk about revolutions
happening in [inaudible] and things
going down in weird,
unpredictable,
negative ways.
You and we've talked about this before,
you let enough of your society fall into
the loser class for lack of a better
word,
winners and losers in society.
If you,
every society can suck up a certain
amount of people not able to to make it,
but if that number gets large enough,
revolutions happen.
I think so too,
but I think the revolution doesn't
necessarily have to be violent.
I think the revolution can be a
revolution of action and ideas and I
think that there's a ton of people out
there that are probably listening to
this that would like to be able to do
something else.
Whether it's make furniture,
well,
they don't want a revolution.
They want to do something that's not
sold.
If you make furniture,
you make furniture for a living and you,
you feel a great satisfaction out of
that and you sell that furniture.
Look man for making furniture feels
good.
If you can do that,
you could,
you could cut those corners perfectly
and sand everything down nice and stain
it and then it's done and you get
dissatisfied and you sell it to someone
and that pays your bills.
That is infinitely more satisfying than
being stuck in some fucking cubicle
working for someone that you don't want
to work for.
Having to have these stupid fucking
office meetings,
talking to people in human resources,
sitting down with your supervisor,
where they evaluate your job performance
and you know,
you're not really,
you know,
you really need to be enthusiastic about
this company,
this company is your future.
This kind of like,
and you're like,
fuck,
kill me now.
You know,
there's a lot of people out there that
would way rather do something else.
And I hope they understand that they
can.
And that's what's funny about that cause
we were in,
because we've been talking about us and
podcasting in new medium,
whatever.
But,
but really,
and I tell,
I give,
I rarely like to give advice because you
know,
you don't wanna you don't wanna be
responsible for people acting on it and
having it not turn out well.
But what I tell people is two things.
Right now,
the United States of America,
the way it's built is built to help
industry and corporations and companies.
But that doesn't necessarily mean it has
to be Microsoft.
It can be you,
right?
You can have your own.
And let's talk about the furniture
builder.
Once upon a time,
there are huge things in your way,
including needing to get loans and all
these other things to just start a
business.
So you're behind the eight ball right
away and the pressures on,
because if it doesn't work,
you're in debt.
Whereas we started these podcasts,
there's no brick or mortar.
I mean,
now you've got just the,
the,
the Rogan Tower.
It's a little bit different,
but once upon a time it's like in the
back of your bedroom and you've got a
company and it's got a show and people
are listening.
If you make your furniture and you don't
have to have a brick and mortar store,
but you can put a website up,
uh,
make it with squarespace or one of those
other things and all of a sudden you
have a business out of your house.
The freedom,
the satisfaction,
the ability to set your own hours.
And here's the best part,
the fact that if you start making a lot
of money somehow you're not going to
have your boss cut your commissions.
I mean I knew sales guys who made so
much money that their bosses cut their
commissions cause you can't make more
than your bosses.
Well listen,
when you have your own small business,
the sky is the limit.
If you make $10 million,
you make $10 million.
So I always tell people that if you can,
and it's not always something they can
do,
maybe you do it on the side when you've
got your regular job.
Starting a small business now in this
climate that we have right now is not
only possible,
it's not that much of a gamble.
Because if worst comes to worst,
you didn't invest $100,000
you didn't have starting at all the
time,
right?
I mean that website didn't cost you that
much.
You know,
the,
the investment for the tools you may
have had already.
Podcasting is a perfect example.
We make business like my buddy says we
sell Zeros and ones.
That's what we do.
Well,
it's been never been easier to have a
website either knows or with companies
like squarespace,
you can develop a website.
You could literally build amazing
website and sell your furniture and you
have a free online store with it and you
put you,
they have these drag and drop user
interfaces.
You use photos and drag them onto their
sides and in place,
boom.
Next thing you know you've got a
website,
so your furniture.
So whatever the fuck you make,
whether you make clothes or you're
designing backpacks or there's,
there's a lot of people out there that
have interests and they've never pursued
those interests because they're fucking
tired from doing some higher soul suck.
It's hard to go to work and put your
effort into that and then come home and
then work for yourself.
It's very hard.
But I'll tell you what,
there's,
there's a part,
like you said,
there's a part of it that once you start
making stuff for yourself,
that self motivating,
right?
Like I told somebody to start a podcast
and I said the first time you get some
feedback email that will kick you in the
rear end to keep doing the pie.
It becomes,
it becomes,
um,
you know,
life is a verb,
I always say.
And you have to actually act,
but by acting you change everything in
your future.
Um,
another guy said to me,
it's a great line.
He said with podcasts,
it's not always how many people are
listening.
Sometimes it's who they are,
right?
So my grandmother's philosophy was
always that you should keep walking and
talking.
But in her era,
walking and talking meant going and
shaking people's hands.
And now you can network like through the
Internet and you never really shaking
people's hands.
But you may have a podcast for the only
a hundred listeners,
but if one of those listeners,
just some guy somewhere else who says,
oh my God,
this guy's furniture is great,
or whatever,
I'm going to,
I'm gonna,
maybe you can come and start giving a
pottery barn.
You know what I mean?
Things open up in ways that you can't
predict because you started doing
something and because you have
legitimate passion for what you can in
that resonates.
Doesn't it feel experience that?
Yeah,
if they seem fine.
I mean,
I can't tell you how many artists that
I've discovered online just through
instagram or through twitter,
like this isn't sent me to creative
revolution in a,
in an amazing way.
And I hope,
and I think there's way more creative
people out there,
then we realize,
Oh yes,
absolutely.
And I think they would love to have some
sort of an opportunity to do something
like that.
And especially like an artist,
someone who is an artist,
man,
there's never been a better time to be
an artist because you could showcase
your work and,
and,
and look,
if you send me something cool
and you know,
he sent it to me on twitter or I'll do,
we treat things all the time.
And all that takes is someone else has
to see that and say,
wow,
that's amazing.
And then two,
two,
two.
It just propagates to all these
different people's instagram feeds and
all these people,
twitter feeds.
And next thing you know,
you've got a business and you're up and
running and it's not going to be easy
and it's not going to be quick.
But the job you're doing now,
ladies,
your cricket,
the soul killing one,
eight easier quickie that people think
like,
oh,
how long is it going to take?
Oh,
but you know when you start out doing a
podcast,
when we got turned downloads,
well that's how it works.
Next call where there was,
I was there once.
Dude,
when we first did it,
when we,
we,
when Brian and I were first doing this
podcast and we were doing it on like
Ustream,
we would have 200 viewers and I wasn't
doing it for money.
I wasn't.
I was literally doing it because my,
my wife had gotten pregnant.
We had to move from Colorado back to La
and I was bummed out and I was like,
fuck,
I thought I escaped.
I thought I got out of La,
I was living in the mountains.
I was like,
this is what I want.
I want to be in nature.
I was like,
I don't want to be back in this fucking
hell hole.
Like all right,
let's do something.
And so we started doing podcasts just
for a goof cause I was doing stand up.
That was all well and good and how it
tied into your standups on,
yeah.
Well,
but it started,
my point is it didn't start out.
I didn't start out thinking this is
going to replace my income.
This is going to be,
I just did it as a passion project and I
think if people have a regular day job,
if you could just find some one thing
that you do as a passion project and
just keep building on it,
just keep at cheap watering it,
keep adding fertilizer,
keep giving it attention,
keep giving it focus and you can escape,
you can escape and you can be self
serving.
You could be okay.
You're going to be okay.
I always ask people when they want to
start it like a podcast.
I'll say something like,
how many listeners would you have to
have for you to care?
Right?
And that's an magic number that's
different for everybody,
right?
But,
but what,
what's great about what we do that's
different from broadcasting is that
there is a giant pie of people.
Let's pretend it's a billion.
And if you're going to do a podcast on
science fiction comic books from the
1950s or something that there's such a
narrow audience,
they'd never put it on television
because it's,
it's too narrow.
You will be able,
if you even get 0.01%
of that billion pie,
it's not only going to be a decent
number of people in terms of what you
would think is successful,
but they're going to be so enthusiastic
because this is an outlet that they
don't have.
It's like I always tell somebody,
if you're into Harry Potter,
what are the TV networks given you?
But there's multiple Harry Potter
podcasts.
Listen to this.
You want to hear something crazy.
Time magazine just had some top 50
podcast thing and a buddy of mine who
was angry that he wasn't on,
sent me some stuff about it.
And uh,
one of the things he said,
dude,
there's a fucking podcast on there
called the Gilmore boys.
That's guys two guys sitting around
talking about the Gilmore Girls
Television show.
There's another one called something
about Richard Simmons where there's
finding Richardson,
Richard Simmons,
where they're trying to figure out why
Richard Simmons went into hiding.
What's so great about that idea though,
and again,
and you at home can learn this too.
What's so great about that idea is that
they instantly tied their podcast to
somebody who already had tons of fan,
right?
So you sit there and go,
I don't know who these guys are or what
this spot,
but I'm a huge Richard Simmons Fan.
So I'll listen.
And that's like instant audience.
Isn't this another podcast called guys?
We fucked these girls cramp came up with
this podcast.
And this is one that I always use an as
example because these who were the girls
from God's,
we fucked.
You see it?
Find the names.
Um,
these,
uh,
comedians from New York,
they came and they actually going to be
on the podcast Monday.
Oh,
that was a clever tie.
And I didn't mean to,
but I used them as an example because,
cause we just booked this earlier today.
Christina Hutchinson and Corinne
[inaudible],
Jimmy Curran Fisher,
and they came up with this clever idea
for the title and it became huge and me,
it's always top 10 it's like one of the
top 10 comedy podcasts and people say,
oh well too,
it's a traded.
No it's not stupid.
You just just to do something that's
good.
Stop saying it's saturated.
If you're good,
it'll stand out.
This idea that [inaudible],
everybody's got these stupid barriers
they put in their own head.
You've got to resist those goddamn
things cause they don't do you any good
and they certainly defined the potential
for your future in a negative way that's
not self serving and it's not even real.
You know,
you've,
you've put this artificial ceiling on
the potential for what you're doing.
If you hit a wall,
okay,
that just means you need to regroup and
rethink.
It doesn't mean that wall's there.
Especially when it comes to something
like social media or like a podcast,
something where you're just,
you're putting out a piece of art,
you're putting out something that you've
created.
There's no wall as far as like how many
people are gonna enjoy it or how far
it's gonna go.
It's just,
it is what it is.
And if people don't like it,
make it better.
If they like it less fixed that,
figure out a way to do it.
You can do that.
And this,
this idea that there's no way to get
past the starting block today is just
ludicrous.
It's crazy.
And it's just this,
this poor thinking and people that are
trapped in bad situations,
one of the problems is you feel like
this is your future.
You feel like you're fucked and you
can't get out of that.
There's no hope.
There's no light at the end of the
tunnel.
There's no rainbow.
And if you feel like that,
that alone can be incredibly defining
and limiting.
But if you can look at,
if you look at yourself objectively and
say,
okay,
I Connie,
I am fucked here.
I'm in credit card debt.
I'm working in a shitty job.
I don't like what I'm doing,
but I have some ideas I need to feed
those fucking ideas and that I need to
feed them.
And water them and I need to set aside a
certain amount of time every day to just
try to make those things happen.
You can do that.
I have a wii.
I like visual images.
You know,
we use that in the hardcore history a
lot.
These,
you know,
what's it like to fight an elephant with
a spear and things like that.
I like,
but the image to die,
that's what it's like.
The image I have though for what you're
talking about.
I've always thought it's a little like a
running back in football who takes the
ball and who goes forward and there's no
hole,
right?
All you run into is the back of your
offensive linemen,
but if you keep hitting,
if a hole is going to open up,
boom,
you'll squirt through.
Now there's no guarantee in life.
The whole will be there.
But there is a guarantee that if you're
not continually smacking at it,
then when it opens up,
you won't be ready.
Right,
right.
And so I don't know about you,
Joe.
You've had a charmed life I think,
and how well you've done.
But I mean,
some of us have failed many times.
I've failed at a bunch of shit.
But I guess what I'm saying is I
remember being a TV reporter at a small
station,
uh,
and,
and I would get out of work at like
midnight and the Sh and the story that I
just spent all day on aired and it was
awful.
And I would get out and I would
literally,
this is when I still had quite a bit of
hair.
I would sit there and like you like pull
your hair out,
you go,
what am I doing?
Right,
right.
This is horrible.
And I look back on those now and I
think,
you know,
what if you had just given up then,
right,
or the podcast,
I mean,
do you know how my wife did a great
thing for me?
Uh,
we,
we'd had that company that I just told
you about it.
We were trying to do the new media thing
and it just fell apart like everybody's
companies were starting to do.
And I wasted a lot of time.
And a lot of money in my life doing
that.
And she would have been totally
justified in saying that's it.
You know you're going to Indianapolis
gonna a talk radio show job wherever
they're higher.
But she did and she said,
you know what,
you tried to try this next thing,
you could do it,
you can and here we are.
And I think,
you know,
if you hadn't tried,
it's that weird thing of it.
And folks,
I tried being a TV reporter,
I'd try b.
You try all those things and either
they're not successful or they're
moderately successful or they're
successful but not enough for you.
You got life is a verb.
You have to,
you know the thing that people that
makes people the most sad in life.
And I already have a couple of friends
my own age who are there is the regrets,
right?
They don't,
they don't,
they're not sorry,
they failed.
They're sorry they didn't try.
And the funny thing is there,
some of them are only 50 and they think,
okay,
my my,
my window to try is already gone.
And which is wrong too.
But folks,
you will be so happy.
There's so many things that have
happened in my life because I,
I mean I got my first talk radio show
job.
I was,
I was a reporter.
I covered the story.
There was some big guy showing up at the
local radio station.
As I was leaving,
I wrote a letter to the program
director.
Just say thanks for having us to thought
do I may have this joint not mail it.
Do I mainly do it and just,
you know,
I closed my eyes and a male that he
called me two days later.
He said,
you want a job?
What if you didn't send that letter?
It's a stupid,
the little things that your life can
hinge on but if you don't do them you
don't give and opportunity to intervene.
I think here's an important thing to
failure is important.
It is important.
I think failure teaches you things that
you don't learn from success.
I think failure gives you an opportunity
for self examination and also gives you
a feeling that is very uncomfortable and
that very uncomfortable feeling helps
you grow that when you feel like shit
and you screw something up.
Like when I've had bad podcasts,
my podcast has always gotten better
afterwards.
When I've had bad standup sets,
I've always gotten better after that
because those bad sets motivate you.
They get,
they give you a perspective like,
Hey,
here's some clear examples of where you
fucked up,
what not to do.
Don't and don't look these failures
as like proof that you suck.
Look at them as opportunities for
growth.
Look at them as opportunities to be
motivated to do better.
And Winston Churchill had a line about
reading quotes about how inspirational
reading famous quotes were.
And he says they motivate you from a
number of different ways,
including the idea that you know,
you think it's just you or you think
that these people who did so well,
we're so incredibly gifted or privileged
from the get go.
And when you realize,
no,
they're more like me than I think that
becomes inspirational.
Right?
You telling your audience,
this is inspirational.
You don't want to hear,
go back to school,
go to this word note,
but if you hate your job,
that is like nature telling you to try
something different and it's motivating
because the motivation is you might not
have to do that soul killing job
anymore.
Well,
if you look at someone who's doing
really well,
I'd say if you focus on like Kevin Hart
or something like that,
some very famous and successful
comedian,
all you see is him now flying around on
private jets wearing a new pair of
sneakers every day driving around in
bentleys.
You just see that.
You don't see him being a young kid in
Philadelphia,
going to open mic nights,
scratching and Clawing Mc Hammer selling
the tapes out of the hatchback.
Yeah,
all of that stuff,
man.
There's a path and you,
we think of people like you see an old
person walking down the street,
you go,
oh,
that person's always been an old person.
Now that was a baby.
That was a baby.
That became a 90 year old man.
There's a,
there's a progression that you are not
witnessed too.
You don't see it and that,
that,
that takes place in everything.
It takes place in author as it takes
place in comedians and musicians,
there is a starting point.
And then with time and focus and as long
as you reevaluate and reassess and
constantly objectively look at what
you're doing and then pursue it with
passion and focus,
you get better at things.
And you know what,
doing all those things ends up,
you know,
it's funny,
but your life experiences create who you
are and all those things actually make
you a more,
for me,
I know I'm speaking,
speaking to the choir here but,
but all those things make you a more
formidable person so that eventually
that next endeavor is,
is you're more prepared for and you're
more formidable and,
and so,
you know,
you turn around,
you say,
what was I like as a 23 year old intern
compared to what I'm like now?
And I'm basically a different person and
you're a different person because of all
these life experiences.
I mean you go to a Centcom meeting with
the big breath,
well,
you're more formidable afterwards,
right?
For sure.
But if you don't put yourself in the
position,
you know it's,
it's life is like coming up to the,
to the plate and taking a swing.
There are no guarantees you're going to
get a hit,
no guarantee.
And you might even look foolish
swinging,
but there's no chance of it if you don't
get in the batter's box.
Right.
On hundred percent.
And one of the things that I've found
over the last few years in particular,
um,
I've done in the past,
but I did it because they were just
goals that I was pursuing on the side as
well as doing standup and all the other
things that I do with my life.
But I've found that things that are
completely unrelated to my career that
are difficult,
enhance what I do,
whether it's yoga or running hills or
archery or all these things
that I incorporate them into what you do
sort of.
But that's just cause I,
my,
one of the things that I do is just talk
about things that I'm interested in,
but they make my,
my focus better because they're hard and
because I'm not good at them.
So like when I do yoga,
I'm not good at Yoga.
So when I do it,
it's hard.
It's a fucking struggle.
And forcing myself to get through that
90 minute class and try a 100% with
every pose enhances my stamina for
thinking and approaching other things.
Let's macro it out a little bit because
I'm very interested in what you're
saying.
So,
so here you and I are talking to the
listeners,
many of whom were already accomplished
and well into their goals.
But if they're not,
they're listening to this.
And I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
if you're trying to design a society,
you know,
we had talked about revolution.
If too many people are,
are the losers in the society.
If you said to yourself,
what really matters in the society's
making more Americans who are happier
with their lives,
more successful doing what they want to
do,
in other words,
empowering them to create.
How different is that in terms of a
setup from what our school system's
designed to do now,
which is a hold over to essentially make
good factory workers,
right?
I mean if you said to somebody,
listen,
this entire country is built for you to
become a businessman with your own
business.
You Start Your own club.
If you taught that in the schools from
the get go and you had workshops all
and,
and everybody's going to say,
damn,
we already do that in the schools.
I already know.
But I mean if that was the entire goal
of your education to turn every student
in that class and do a small business
person doing their own dreams someday,
how would you do it differently than
what you do now?
Because to me the biggest crime isn't
that we had the kind of system we have
is that we're not training people on how
to utilize it.
And,
I mean,
we have all these opportunities there
and it sounds like a cliche,
but we're doing it.
And as you go through it,
you say to yourself,
well,
why can't more people do this?
Well,
who told them they could?
And who said,
you know,
I mean,
this is a little bit of a handholding,
but I'm teaching this to my kids right
now,
right?
I'm telling them,
listen,
don't go do the soul killing job,
uh,
work on this thing that you seem to be
good at and that you love and let's work
on it.
Now what the,
I mean,
I guess what I'm saying is,
could we be doing a better job here?
Uh,
and if,
if so,
you know,
would you have to fight teachers unions
to do it?
What do you have to do to break apart a
system that's 140 years old and not
working all that well right now?
Two more correspond to the reality that
people are growing up in now.
Well,
I had a conversation with my daughter
yesterday about this,
my nine year old and she to do it,
but she was saying,
she was saying,
school is so boring.
I don't want to go to school more.
And when she was laughing about,
I was picking her up from a class that
she goes to and uh,
I said,
well,
what's the most boring?
She goes,
it's all boring to spend funny.
Right,
right.
And I go,
well,
you like reading and you're,
you're,
you're really into reading.
She goes,
yeah,
I do.
I like it.
But they make it boring.
She goes,
they make reading boring.
And she goes,
they make,
I go,
but you like writing,
right?
You're like writing shows.
I like writing what I want to write
about.
They make writing bars,
she's creative,
but she was being silly.
But the wisdom from a nine year old,
we were just laughing and having fun
talking about it.
But the wisdom from a nine year old
expressing how they make things that she
likes boring.
It's like,
I think there's a certain amount that
you have to do that's boring,
right?
There's a certain amount of the hard
work,
even in your business that you're sure
learning,
grammar,
learning language,
certain amount of that stuff,
it's fucking boring.
Once you get past that boring shit and
you have a base understanding of how to
communicate and how to add,
how to count,
how to multiply,
how government works,
all these different things that you
should have sort of a base understanding
of.
Then it's like everyone has a different
personality.
They have different,
different interests,
different different things that they
would be really satisfied pursuing
that's not encouraged.
The what's encouraged encourages go find
a job.
What's encouraged is go find some place
that you can shove yourself into.
Go find a square hole that you can stick
your round peg and just fucking jamming
in there and shave down the top and the
bottom.
So you slide in with all this extra
space on the sides and feel like shit
for the rest of your life because you
need a job because you're in debt
because you have credit cards because
you have student loans because that's
what everybody does and so you do it
too.
That's what's wrong.
What's wrong is that we don't like we
don't give,
it's like we met,
let them figure it out on their own and
it fucking takes forever.
It takes,
it took forever for me.
My,
the only thing that I had going for me
that was that I was crazy and that I had
been spending most of my high school
years fighting so that I was already so
far outside of anybody that I was so
weird.
I didn't fit in anywhere.
It was weird too.
Isn't that funny?
I didn't feel like I had a pot.
I knew one thing.
I couldn't work like a regular job.
Like I had to figure out something else.
Cause I think there's the idea of,
it was literally the idea of being in an
office was like torture.
Can I just tell you,
so that's the hinge point.
The difference between you and this.
So,
so here's if I was,
if I was creating a fantasy educational
system,
the hinge point between what you just
said is that you said,
I couldn't stand this.
I couldn't work the real job.
I couldn't fit into this.
So I did something,
I had to find another way.
A lot of people get stuck with the,
so I had to find another way apart.
Yeah.
Um,
you know it's funny cause you know your
kids are young enough to,
so you went through this,
but I mean when my kids were really
young before they were in the school
there and now we put them in one of
those Montessori schools.
You know the ones that everybody goes
together.
No,
it's,
it's different school to school.
But,
but the basic concept is that you don't
force the children to learn anything
specific.
You have all these things around and the
children go to work they want to do.
Um,
so the upsides obviously that from the
get go they're only reading what they're
into.
Or the downside of course is that
there's all this other stuff you're
supposed to,
to learn.
It's the Diet.
It's the dichotomy between how do you
know,
you,
you had talked about needing to have
these skills,
a little math skills.
You need some basic foundational stuff,
but something also happening at
that level,
which is you're finding out which
students are into math and would like to
have a career in math.
Other people are being touched by a
foreign language in a way that they
think I'd like to learn more than I'd
like to speak in fluent.
I'd like to teach it.
So in a way,
you're already beginning to select what
kids are into by exposing them to this
stuff.
Most of us find it boring,
but there might be something.
That's where I first found history as a,
as a discipline,
right?
If,
if most kids is,
Oh God,
the last thing I want to hear some
history,
but I get turned on by it.
Okay,
well we'll then it's worth exposing you
to all those things.
Um,
I think the problem is though is that it
would be great,
for example,
to have half your schooling,
maybe at that young age,
be sort of a Montessori model where you
say,
okay,
we spend our time on reading,
writing,
and arithmetic.
Now we want you to go around and it has
to be,
you can't be playing video games and
less playing video games is what you
want to do for a living and you're going
to be able to,
to do some educational work on it.
But I mean,
I would love to see more of a fostering
for the fact that,
listen,
we're trying to create entrepreneurs
here rather than trying to create drone
workers on the Amazon assembly line.
Now if you end up on the Amazon assembly
line anyway,
great.
Good for you.
I'm glad you can bring some food home.
But the goal ought to be to let you
start a business and maybe employ a
bunch of other people,
you know?
Yeah.
And the goal would be to have less
unhappy,
dissatisfied p that because it creates a
more stable society.
Well,
it also happier.
Yeah.
It creates more,
more satisfaction in the people that I
know that get to do what they want to do
for a living.
It's not like they're,
their lives are completely how
everybody's going to,
that's what its problems.
No matter who you are,
you know what a,
it was a Kanye west who said to rich
people have problems or just different
problems.
I mean it's,
everybody's got these challenges,
but like you said,
there's not a lot more more stressful
than having a ton of credit card debt
wondering,
you know,
if you're going to lose your house,
wondering how you're going to pay for
your kids' education.
I mean all those things are soul
crushing.
Not only that,
because you're in debt,
you get nervous.
So it suppresses your ability to take
risks,
take risks,
cause you're in your cycle.
You don't want to lose your Gig.
You don't want to,
you know,
it's like man,
then you're tired,
you're tired.
I mean the one thing is as you get
older,
I mean it's funny because I'm getting
older is one of those things that you
can only understand when you get there.
So I all through your life,
you're going through these,
God isn't it?
Isn't this the interesting part of being
in your 30s or being in your foot?
So as I go into my 50s now,
I'm sitting here going,
energy is so under talked about,
you know,
the ability to,
like my buddy who wrote me and said,
you know,
I feel like I screwed up my life.
I didn't take enough chances.
I played it safe and now I'm so unhappy.
He says,
and I just can't motivate myself at 50
years old any more energy wise to start
over,
energy is underrepresented.
It's hard.
Guys got to fix his health.
I knew you were going to say that.
See what it is.
Your health is your engine.
It helped is literally the,
the chassis,
the tires,
the brakes,
the engine of your vehicle that you move
through this life with.
And too many people don't pay attention
to it at the end of the lack of energy
is,
and as you get older,
especially not just that,
it,
it changes your ability to do things.
If you don't have energy,
not only will you not have the energy to
pursue things,
but you won't,
you won't be able to do them the same
way.
If you have energy and enthusiasm and
say like you're healthy and you want to
write a book,
you're going to have thoughts that will
come into your mind that won't come into
your mind if you're exhausted.
Agreed.
That's fucking huge.
That's huge for anything you're trying
to pursue.
Whether we're talking about furniture
making,
what they're talking about,
being an author,
whatever it is.
Let's talk about ideas for a minute
because I think that's another one.
When we talk about small businesses or
starting as an entrepreneur,
you know,
I'm one of those people that is not sure
that we don't have a finite number of
ideas to each of us and all of them are
valuable enough even if they don't
appear to be on the surface to write
down.
Um,
you know,
I,
as a matter fact,
I keep,
I went to a business meeting a couple of
years ago with one of these TV guys I
was just talking about and we go to this
business meeting and you know,
we're all on our phones and whatever and
he pulls out an old fashioned journal
that you write in and he's just starts
writing.
And I looked at that and I thought in
one sense he looks like a dinosaur,
but I went out and bought one and now
it's crazy how often,
you know,
all I do is write ideas in it and a lot
of them I look back on now and I go,
okay,
that's still stupid.
But other ones I look back on and go,
God,
I didn't know what this idea meant at
the time,
but five years later this idea is
really,
you know,
I guess what I'm saying is,
is that if you wanted to take almost
like a religious view of it,
God only gives you somebody that right
down and cherish the ideas.
But there is something to that folks.
What really is going to make you unique
sometimes is the way your brain works
differently than anyone's brain who's
ever existed on the planet.
That's valuable right there.
Write down what comes out of the brain.
Um,
because you capture those calves are
don't tap to them.
They will slip around and sometimes,
sometimes the idea isn't good until you,
until the second half arrives later,
right?
So idea number ones in your book from
five years ago.
Idea number two that finally completes
that.
Id arrives later.
I mean,
I had a friend who was so creative and
he said he gets the best ideas at night.
So he just turns on the light and the
light at the side of the table writes it
down in the book and by morning there's
another idea down there.
And quantity has a quality all its own.
And sometimes a book filled with
interesting ideas out of your individual
unique head will help you later on.
So write them down.
Yeah.
There's no downside.
I have an APP on my phone where I can
just,
uh,
you know the notes app?
Yes,
use that microphone filled.
Let's talk into that.
I do too.
And it dictates it really almost
perfectly.
So I'll have an idea and I'll just be
driving down the road.
I just press that button.
I started talking into it and then I put
it down.
I got it.
Like I got that one a captured it.
Think about people who've had one
fantastic idea and their life and built
their whole life on it.
And you never know which idea that's
going to be.
And you know what,
I,
I was an Improv again.
You know more about this than I do,
but I was a theater major for my first
two years of college and we,
we did improv comedy and the Guy who
taught us Improv in high school really?
He had a great line.
He said that part of your brain,
like every part of your brain is a
muscle.
And he said,
the more you're thinking,
okay,
I got to show this Friday that I have to
come up with something funny for the
better.
You get at it and,
and,
and you start looking,
your brain starts looking at things and
finding thing.
So you're almost like training it to
help you now in this new endeavor.
It's a very plastic sort of an approach.
But,
but it's the same thing with the ideas.
One idea in your little book that you
wrote down could make your life,
your child.
I mean if you're a Henry Ford,
I mean,
how many people did you employ for
decades afterwards because of a good
idea.
I mean,
our world is built on those things.
And also like the idea of having these
ideas and the enthusiasm that comes from
it.
Like it starts to escalate and you start
to calculate like,
oh,
and I need more.
And I think this and maybe that.
And,
and then the,
the motivation and the momentum of these
ideas can lead to enthusiasm.
You attract other people who have,
who can add,
I mean this is what we said about like
you start your website and you just do
it because things,
once you push the,
the verb of living manages to create
ripples into get ultimate metaphysical
ubit ripples in time in front of you.
That open up possibilities and because
someone may,
if you only have one podcast listener
but that podcast listeners like,
wow,
that's great.
I'm going to and gets a hold of you and
your life goes off in another different
direction.
But you have to try.
You have to try.
Yeah,
well you don't have to,
you could just drone on,
but no,
I would recommend not doing that.
I would also suggest that you and I and
everyone has an interest in,
in not allowing people to drone on too
much because,
because for the same reason I talked
about Insta,
we did a common sense show once called
the revenge of the gangrenous finger.
And the idea was that,
you know,
if you ignore people in your society
that aren't doing well long enough,
it's a little like saying yes,
my finger has gang green,
but it's the little ones,
so who the hell cares?
But eventually if you ignore it long
enough,
it will poison your bloodstream and
destroy the body itself.
If you have enough people in soul
crushing situations who can't,
you know,
a guy called me once on the radio when I
was preaching revolution in the middle
of 1990s and said,
you're an idiot.
He said you're an idiot because no one's
going to face the bay.
Annette's as long as they have enough
food in their bellies and they're doing
halfway.
Okay.
But of course the implication there is
if they don't have food in their bellies
and they're not doing okay,
then all bets are off.
We all have a vested interest in seeing
that more of our country men do better
because it's better for the society as a
whole creates a better world for your
kids.
Happier.
I mean,
there's so many.
And the one thing about our system,
you know,
people talk about patriotism all the
time.
Uh,
but to me the real patriotism is saying,
we've created a system here.
It works this way.
It encourages people to go do these
things.
So if the system's designed and set up
for that,
you ought to give it a try.
You ought to just see,
know the suggestion that I always give
to people is write down things that you
want to try to accomplish.
Just write them down.
Or a guy said to,
he said,
who said right the way you want your
obituary to appear?
Now sit down,
write your obituary.
He says,
because that'll show you how far off
your goals you are.
Here's a,
here's a better one.
Pretend there's a documentary crew
filming your success story and they're
following you around right now.
What would you do?
What would you do if you knew that there
was a crew following you around with
cameras documenting your future?
Incredible success,
and they want to catch you in the act of
at all.
You would do all the right things.
You would have to do.
Think about that,
organize it.
But we're,
we are saddled down by so many doubts
and so,
so much just mental horse shit that
keeps people from,
uh,
from action.
But look at the thing,
that's,
to me maybe the number one thing that's
the impediment and the make society
unequal.
It's,
it's the luck of who your parents are.
That's a big one.
I mean,
if,
if you say,
listen,
this guy grew up and started his own
business because his folks taught in
those kinds of things and encouraged him
when he is or she with her creativity.
Okay,
that's a person that's got a huge
advantage in life.
We talked about white privilege giving
you an advantage.
Well,
good parent privilege gives you an
advantage.
But then the question that as if you're
looking at it macro in a society since
that comes up is okay,
what,
what can society do if you say this is a
real problem for the rest of us,
not enough good parents,
cause those people never learned it.
How do you compensate for that?
And that almost gets a little
socialistic where you're talking about
the state teaching you creativity and it
doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense,
but there's got to be,
if we decide that this is a national
security interest,
you know,
having more Americans live in the dream
have less losers.
But what if your parents are losers?
Yeah,
well you can get past that.
I know a lot of people that are fucking
losers for parents.
Could we increase the,
the,
the number of people,
you know,
if you say,
okay,
500 out of a thousand overcome that,
how do you get to 600 how do you get to
700 out of a thousand and if you say
it's a national security concern that we
do,
I mean I think ambition is a gene.
I really do.
And I think that that some of us,
you could be born into any circumstance,
but you've got this gene so you're going
to be ambitious and you're going to
overcome it.
Then I think there's people who have no
ambition gene and there's nothing you
can do to help them.
And then I think there's a huge number
of people in the middle that could go
either way.
And the question I have is,
you don't have to help the ones with the
gene.
You can't do anything for the ones
without the gene.
How do you increase the odds for the
people who could go either way?
I think you give them a template.
You give them some,
some markers that they can follow.
Who's we though?
I mean,
they're little me.
Yes,
it's yes.
Okay.
Anybody who has maybe gone,
anybody who's ahead.
Here you go,
hey,
come on,
come this way.
I mean that's,
there's a responsibility that we have
for each other.
What about last and Canadian businesses?
I mean,
you know,
you look at some of these,
um,
in the little town where it was a little
town,
Eugene,
Oregon,
where I live now,
they have a above Eugene,
by the way,
you know,
it's great if you're from Los Angeles,
green,
it's,
I liked boulder where you live.
I went to college there.
Um,
but if you are living in a place like
that,
they have a venture capitalist angel
investor thing for people who are
starting small businesses and it's not a
government deal,
although the counties,
and I think of a little bit,
but,
but it's one of those things where you
go,
okay,
if this is a good idea,
could we be doing more of this where you
joe blow
wants to start a business,
he needs $100,000
to do it.
Uh,
if you go to a bank,
they're never going to approve it
because you have too much credit card
debt.
Could we as a society say,
hey,
we have an interest in Joe blow doing
well,
would that furniture company,
what can we do to help?
I think the pie in the sky,
the better thing would be the not have
alone to try to figure out how to do
without a alone.
I agree.
Beautiful things about kickstarter and
go fund me.
Is it,
you know,
you can,
you could raise money now.
We don't need a storefront.
Oh,
you don't need anything.
Yeah.
You know,
I just,
I just feel like people need inspiration
and they need guidelines.
And if long as you could just start
moving,
just get action.
Like you just getting,
just movement,
get such as a girl you got,
yeah.
And folks listen,
that's the one thing you really take out
of this is that just try and see what
happens.
And my stepfather had a great line.
He said,
what's the worst that can happen?
Yeah.
And you know,
sometimes you have to think about that
to realize if you're scared about
failure,
don't be scared of it.
The greatest in the world have failed.
If you're worried about going into debt,
I understand that.
Don't be scared of failure.
I think failure is awesome for you.
And that's one of the reasons why,
like I said,
I like doing things that I suck at.
You know,
there's,
you could get real complacent if you're
really good at something and you only do
that thing all the time.
Agree with that and you're not growing
anymore.
You're just not challenged.
You're not like,
you're not at the bottom of the heap.
You know,
if you start Jujitsu right now and
you're a white belt,
you're like,
Oh God,
what the fuck?
How,
how can I ever get good at this?
And it's,
it's humbling.
But in that humbling thing,
you learn about yourself,
you learn about discipline and you build
up that engine,
that muscle that is trying to work
things out and figure things out,
creating a more formidable you.
Yeah.
It's a good way to look at it.
Now as a historian,
you know,
and [inaudible] like to say that you are
motherfucker,
I would didn't teach teacher you
probably one of the most important
historians ever.
How about that fuck face.
Don't know what,
I'm speechless.
But as someone who is a fan of history,
how about this,
I'll tell you got it more palatable for
you.
Um,
how do you look at,
what do you do you look at like what's
going on with this administration and
with this country and this the,
I mean,
our president is he,
he tweeted at the,
at Kim Jong [inaudible] saying that Kim
Jong owns said that I'm old.
I don't know why he said that because I
never say that he's short and fat and
like maybe we can be friends.
I'm just like,
he's like Don rickles as president.
Fucking hilarious.
But do you look at it in terms of like
one day someone is going to do a
hardcore history series about the trump
administration?
Do you ever look at it that way?
Do you look at it in terms of like,
like establishing a narrative or like
trying to describe it to the two people
some day?
I think we're too in the Maelstrom,
like we said earlier,
for me to figure that out,
I will say that I see a certain side
benefits.
So for example,
you know,
one of the things that I've talked about
for many,
many years,
and we did a whole six hour podcast on
it too,
is the,
is the president's power to launch a
nuclear war all by himself or herself?
Well,
and it's,
here's the thing is that,
that,
that's an obvious flaw.
I mean that's,
and everybody understands it,
but nobody's done anything about it.
So now because everyone's so scared of
trump,
they're talking about fixing a problem
that has,
should have been fixed decades and
decades ago.
Not because he's a great president and
they're looking for,
but because they're so fricking scared
of him and he's so outside.
You know?
I mean,
it's funny because why these politicians
and they'll trust people from the other
parties.
It doesn't matter.
You didn't hear the Democrats saying,
we can't have George W.
Bush with his finger on the nuclear
button.
You didn't hear George W.
Bush.
They were all fine with it.
As long as you're one of those insiders,
the first time you get an outsider in
there,
now they're scared to death.
But they should have been scared to
death decades and decades ago.
So if you said that we have a trump
presidency and the only big thing that
comes out of it,
as they finally fixed that one person
can't launch a nuclear war holocaust by
themselves,
that's a pretty big deal,
right?
The almost had to break a little aspect
of the system for people to freak out
enough to fix it.
But when you think,
look,
worst case scenarios,
you think worst case,
look at World War One is a worst case
scenario.
Um,
if you have a person with the power to
launch a nuclear war by themselves,
if anybody can't see that,
that's an untenable,
horrible situation and you look at human
history and go,
okay,
it's a ticking time bomb.
Literally.
Um,
then you're not,
you don't own very much history.
And the fact that we've escaped decades
and decades without anybody fixing this
problem.
Crazy.
Well,
so if the trump presidency alone caused
us to fix that problem,
you'd have to say that for no,
I mean this wasn't trump's side,
he didn't want to fix that problem.
But as a byproduct of him getting into
office,
if we could fix that problem,
depending on how history went in the
future,
you could be saving 100 million lives.
Yeah.
If you could fix that problem.
But what if we get through the trump
administration and we move ourselves
into 2020 and someone really accepted
into the car dash in administration
after that?
Kanye will you do think,
I mean if,
if a q rating,
the q rating is a is is the,
is how well your name is known,
right?
So if,
if what trump proved is that you do not
need a ton of money if you walk in the
door with a q rating because that's what
the other politicians wanted for.
Right?
Well he's uniquely good at ignoring his
fault and projecting his strengths and
being confident.
All those things.
I mean he might be a sociopath,
but all those things that allow him to
do that and completely ignore his faults
and keep constantly droning on about his
successes and how good he is.
It things that resonates with people in
a very weird way.
We respect and admire the strong man and
people give into him.
There's a lot of halfass bay.
The hate that,
that to me that's so anti-american
though is strong man.
But it is what happened.
That is what happened.
That's why I find it distasteful.
But I will say this,
uh,
there are certain things that he did
that are part of his,
that
that worked really well because it,
there are so many Americans so upset
with the system.
I mean I remember one line from trumpet,
one of these debates that I thought was
one of the great lines of all time.
And when he turned to rand Paul after
Rand Paul slammed him and said,
you're not having a very good night,
are you?
And I remember thinking,
okay,
they're not a lot of Americans who just
love anybody sticking it to these
politicians.
Now because everybody is so upset with
all the pollen.
So here's a guy who's sticking it to
them.
But there's a,
there's a cutting off your nose to spite
your face side of this.
Cause I've always wanted an outsider,
but not this outsider.
So you say to yourself,
okay,
we could have had a normal human being.
Cause look,
if you want to say what trump has,
I don't know the guy,
so I can't diagram when he,
but he's,
he's an extreme narcissist.
Now,
all these people have narcissistic
complexes or you don't think I'm a good
enough guy to be president.
Right.
Right there.
It's almost like you don't get through
the door without too much narcissism.
I've never seen this much from,
uh,
from anybody.
I mean this is,
this is,
but um,
you know,
if if for a while that was working for
him because he was so outside the norms,
there are certain like unspoken rules of
things you do and behave and he violated
all those and it was refreshing to have
him violate them.
Um,
now we have,
I,
well when he told Hillary Clinton
because you'd be in jail and everybody
went nuts.
It's like,
yes,
because a lot of people cause people and
people and people,
you know,
the real thing I think a lot of people
said,
which is tragic,
but I understand it,
is if we have to live with one of these
people for four years and listened to
them talk,
I'd rather have somebody who's making
funny jokes that make me laugh rather
than,
you know,
somebody who's obviously reading another
prepared speech that they didn't.
Exactly.
Or Sony where you really don't get a
sense of who they really are.
Like a Hillary Clinton who is a career
politician,
he's a chameleon.
She's just saying what she thinks the
Poles are going to favor.
So then if,
um,
if you know the part that drives me the
craziest,
it is 321 million people you said and
the two people that we're voting on at
the end of this thing or Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump's hilarious.
That's the problem.
Well nobody wants that fucking
magnifying glass turned on their life.
My stepdad said,
if you,
if you are really August person and,
and you're going to sit there and say
the word to just means you're really
powerful,
formidable human being.
How do you spell it?
Like August.
August.
Yeah.
And so,
so you sit down and if you're,
he said they,
those kinds of people divide a piece of
paper in half and they write pros on one
side and cons on the other and they
running for president and they go down
the pros and the cons and go,
he goes to cons.
Outnumbered the pros five to one.
It might be 100 million.
I'm not going to have as much power as I
have now.
I Blah,
blah,
blah.
Everyone's going to hate you.
And he's,
he's so,
so people who are really intelligent,
if they do that calculation,
the calculation says,
don't run for president.
You'd be an idiot.
Now he says,
people though who run anyway,
it's because something on the pro side
outweighs everything on the con side,
like I want to be on tv all the time,
or I want to be the most powerful person
in the world,
or it's the natural extension.
I've been a senator,
you know,
whatever it is.
In other words,
there's some ego question that's out
that that's drowning all the columns
and,
and he said,
that's why you have to be careful
because that's so,
so either have somebody who's not
intelligent enough to,
to weigh the pros and cons or somebody
who's so smart that the cons outweigh
the pros and they choose to do it
anyway.
What a crazy system.
When you think that that is the way we
develop a person who is going to be in
control of nuclear weapons.
We have a popularity contest where to
when the popularity contest,
which is totally,
you know,
a elective,
you don't have to join,
but to,
to get into this contest and to win,
you're gonna,
you're life's going to be torn apart.
They're going to go over there.
People are going to lie about you and
look at your favorite person and say,
say,
you know,
you go look at some of these candidates
from the past that we'd like to lionize.
Would they have even made it through the
process today?
Imagine what Kennedy would have had to
jog and then it with John Kennedy,
the kind of things that would,
he'd have all these women coming
forward.
Can you imagine it?
Who had never made it?
The doctor feelgood's would show up.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They used to give him like amphetamines.
Right?
You had like some serious disease.
Addison's disease.
Glandula a problem with the glands where
it's not providing adrenaline.
I think,
don't quote me on that.
Wow.
So they had him on some sort of
amphetamines.
So he,
he,
he was apparently on a lot of
medication.
I think he had the last rights given to
him once before because he came so close
to dying.
Well,
and truthfully I read that it impacted
the way he kind of saw his life cause he
didn't expect it to be a long life.
And so it impacted on how,
but if you,
if somebody told you,
Joe,
you're not going to have,
well you're not going to have a long
life.
How much does that change the way you
live the rest of your life?
You probably live crazy.
You probably go navy skiing every day.
He'd skydiving or maybe you try to try
to get the things on your bucket list in
terms of accomplishments done quick more
quickly or,
um,
but,
but you look at someone like that and
said,
could a guy like that it made it through
the process?
Could Lyndon Johnson and made it through
the process get richer?
I mean,
all those people lived at a time period.
That was a lot less of a fishbowl than
today.
And if you say that these great leaders
can't make it through the process,
and the only people that make it through
the process are the ones who've been so
careful,
never taken a risk,
lied like crazy co.
I mean,
if you say those are the only people
that can make it through the process,
then maybe that explains why we 321
million people,
this is the choice we end up with at the
end of the day.
Well,
we also have this problem where we look
at someone's entire life and we look at
all the different things that they do
and we decide whether or not we accept
certain things.
Like we're not talking about whether or
not someone's honest with business,
whether you,
we want you to be honest with
everything.
Yeah.
You gotta be,
you gotta get c average and everything.
You can't have an a in here.
And it wouldn't be the truly great
people as we know,
often very flawed,
very flawed.
And also like what percentage of people
who want to be leaders.
I think about that thing,
right?
You want to be the one on the podium
telling everybody what's up.
What percentage of those guys want to
fuck other women?
Is it a hundred right?
I mean,
I can't answer that,
but if you think about like nature,
like the natural leader types,
like throughout human history,
what percentage of those have been
monogamous?
Those ones who want to control the army,
the ones who want to run the thing.
The ones who want to be at the top,
getting everybody to do their bidding.
The ones who want to have all the money
and all the power and live in the
castle.
Those guys are almost all adulterers,
you know?
It does.
It does argue for the idea that it might
be better to appoint somebody who
doesn't want the job.
It's like somebody had talked to him,
he wants to talk about that with police
officers.
And they had said,
listen,
there are all kinds of police officers,
but if you're the one who wants the job
because you're going to chase bad guys
and you want that adrenaline rush and
the whole thing,
you're not the guy who should get the
job or if the guy wants respect.
Yes.
But well like,
and you can see the funny thing is is,
and somebody sent this to me a long time
ago,
they showed a,
there's all these different um,
like um,
recruitment videos that the different
police agencies have.
Right.
And some of them are more like,
you can get cats out of trees,
you can help old ladies.
And some of them are like,
you can try traffic,
great car.
And,
and,
and the funny thing is,
I would imagine that that influences the
sort of people that answer your ad.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean,
they have billboards in La for to try
where they used to at least to try to
hire new cops.
And they did it based on the money.
Like,
this is how much money you can get.
La PD is paying this mount and they'd
show and you're like,
drive by like,
oh,
I can make that amount.
Okay,
I should try to do that.
John.
If you appointed cops see a billboard,
what I'm saying?
It's like when you're advertising,
it's the same problem you have when
you're advertising for drug companies.
You get people thinking like,
oh,
maybe I need that abilify,
my life.
Oh humira.
Woo.
I need that.
That that seems like I liked the music,
their plan.
I like everybody's dancing.
Oh,
I like how that cop looks up there.
He looks,
he looks for medieval.
He looks like Amanda gets respect.
Look,
he's got his hands on his hips and he's
got a nice car behind him and look as a
female co squad leader with him.
I wonder if he fucks her.
You know,
like people start to look at an ad and
you start imagining yourself in the
position of that person,
in that Ad.
And then next thing you know,
you know you're the one who was going to
go get the bad guys and you're the one
who's going to go.
But yeah,
if you talk to a real cop,
like a good cop is someone who respects
community,
someone who wants to help someone who
wants to establish some sort of a bond
with the people that are in the
community.
The patrols th like that's why they're
trying to do in some neighborhoods are
trying to have more people on foot and
actually walk through the streets and
become a part of the community.
Like don't,
you're not an outsider that's patrolling
it.
You're actually one of the people that's
there.
It goes to what we were saying about the
politicians that are tied it all in.
Why are you doing this?
Right?
Are you doing this because you want to
be the person at the podium that
everybody's,
you know,
admiring the,
you want to be the person that
everyone's talking about or are you
sincerely interested in public service
and helping things?
I mean,
what if you,
I can think of 20 people that you would
say got,
it'd be interesting to see what that
person would do in the presidency,
right?
Yeah.
But like you said,
I can't imagine any of them wanting to
do it to,
none of them are going to want to do
it.
Mark Cuban has want to be the president.
Elon Musk's not,
don't want to be the president.
I think we really need a council.
I think the idea of one second,
that's what it's supposed to do.
Remember,
we're supposed to be,
if everybody remembers their founding
father federalist papers,
I mean the presidency was a much,
much,
much less powerful job.
Right?
This was a country that was run by the
legislative branch basically.
Um,
we're not that way anymore because of a
whole bunch of things,
including the nuclear weapons thing we
talked about earlier.
The,
the,
the atomic age changed the presidency
because of the need to have one person.
You couldn't declare war anymore because
what if the missiles are on their way to
you now?
Right.
Can you really go to Congress and debate
it and have the no,
you needed a person who within 10
minutes could launch a counter strike.
Okay,
well how much power does that take out
of the hands of the legislature who was
supposed to be running things?
For example,
why do we not declare war anymore?
We haven't declared war since the Second
World War.
We have a country that the constitution
says you can't go to war without a
declaration is certainly not that you
can get some barbary pirates cleared out
of North Africa,
but you can't,
like,
that's why Congress,
by the way,
with the trump thing,
is they want to say that you can't
launch nuclear weapons unless less
congress has declared war first,
which creates this wonderful thing about
trying to figure out if we can sort of
retroactively,
um,
replace a power that's been gone since
1942.
You know,
when we,
we declared war on like Romania and
something else.
You did the subsidiary powers in the
Second World War and that's the last
time it's been done.
But according to the constitution,
we shouldn't have been able to fight a
war since without that.
It's going to be very interesting to see
what happens in 2020 it's going to be
really interesting and I to to remove
some of the power that the president has
is going to be a really big uphill
battle unless some would actually drops
a nuke on somebody unless trump decides
to bomb North Korea.
Like Kim John owns says something about
his wife,
like,
could you piece of shit?
You fucking launches a bomb Adam.
Unless it's something so egregious and
ridiculous like that,
it's going to be really hard to dial
back the power without any real specific
need because people are going to
concentrate on all the other issues that
the country faces economically,
militarily,
the need for health care,
the need for to,
you know,
environmental standards.
What are we gonna do about global
warming?
There's so many issues that take the
front stage.
The idea of someone actually launching a
nuclear attack seems so distant and
ridiculous,
but that's not going to be on the
forefront of everybody's like list of
priorities of things to handle.
Makes me think of Eisenhower ordering
the local German population at the end
of the Second World War to go tour the
death camps themselves and actually have
to walk past piles and piles and piles
of human bodies because he wanted them
to not forget why are going to look at
this.
And I,
you know,
I didn't know he did that.
And when you look at the end of the
world wars,
for example,
in both of them,
people were so shocked by what happened.
You get this idea that we're never
again,
right?
We're never going to let this again.
But you get a generation later,
two generations later.
How long does it take for those lessons
to fade away?
So when I hear or read on twitter,
it's probably some 13 year old boy in
his basement.
So you never know.
But the,
the racial stuff,
I always think to myself,
if you only,
you know,
maybe we need some dead bodies out there
so you can go see,
this is what it looks like,
right?
We're not fooling around here.
This kind of stuff leads to this,
uh,
stop fooling around with 140 characters
and look at what real death tastes,
smells like and what the long term
ramifications of pushing these sorts of
attitudes can lead to and has over and
over and over again.
Well,
I think there's a real problem with the
human condition when it comes to
complacency and comfort.
And I think that we get real comfortable
in real complacent and we have a very
distorted idea of what life is without
struggle.
And there's a great book by Sebastian
younger who was on last week and uh,
it's called tribe and he did a perfect
storm too,
is wonderful.
He's amazing.
But talking to him about what happens
when people overcome significant
tragedies,
whether it's war or whether it's natural
disasters or you know,
I was in,
I was in New York right after nine 11
and it was palpable,
the sense of community and how friendly
people were.
And it was because people had had their
world shaken up by an attack and it
literally did good.
It really did good for the people that
survive in a fucked up way.
But it makes me think of that project
for a new America document that before
nine 11 had said that there's,
you know,
without some kind of Pearl Harbor style
attack,
the American system is designed right
now in a way where people are gonna pull
apart more and more.
In other words,
just saying,
you know,
you can almost wish for something like
that to happen to pull us together.
I remember when I was horrible thought
though,
right?
Yeah.
And maybe maybe it's the only way we
learn and you need the refresher,
but that's what I think people need war
in their own life and I think they need
struggle.
I need structure.
They need something to do in their own
life that's incredibly difficult to keep
them from being this to many of us not
place it in mundane.
When I was,
when I was um,
trying to localize the story from the,
the,
the Yugoslavian civil war that we were
just talking about earlier,
I interviewed a Croatian man in Eugene
and we were talking about it and I was
bringing up these age old hatreds and
basically saying,
you know,
they've always hated each other and he
stopped me.
He said,
no,
stop,
stop.
He goes,
we didn't,
he goes,
up until recently we were intermarrying
with each other.
We got along,
it was all working out.
He goes,
do you know what changed?
I said,
what?
He goes,
the economy tanked.
and all of a sudden he goes,
the first thing that started to
resurface when everybody was just hating
everything,
their lives and the,
and everything he has,
all of a sudden,
all these old things that had been
buried just came right back.
And so that tribalism you're talking
about were younger.
I think there are times,
and you had mentioned it,
right,
post postwar errors these times when
they go away,
most disasters,
but then certain kinds of conditions,
for example,
terrible economic conditions for too
many people.
It's funny how quickly the scape goats
come and and
things that,
I mean truthfully,
you mean the biggest thing that I've
missed politically in terms of just,
I just didn't see it was the resurgence
of the racism,
bigotry,
prejudice thing.
I mean I thought,
you know,
we grew up in the era where our country
was trying to figure out through things
like broadcasting,
how we transition.
So you remember all in the family when
it started?
Yeah.
It's a show that doesn't even run very
much anymore because simply trying to
address those issues is too hot button
for most advertisers.
Now.
You could never have an archibald.
No.
And,
but that whole show was part of
society's attempt to transition from an
era where it wasn't that long beforehand
where you couldn't stay in a hotel that
wasn't a black or a white person's hotel
in the south to one where we got now.
And I always thought,
okay,
the message of Archie bunker was they
would try to teach him,
the young people would try to teach you
about how to be a more open human being,
but it didn't matter because the archie
bunker's of the world,
we're going to die off.
They were the dinosaurs from another
era.
And eventually that would be a way of
looking at things.
That was in the past.
And I,
I thought that that was what it was
going to be.
And I never,
I never saw the resurgence,
but like my Croatian friend had said,
just maybe things had to get bad enough
economically and whatever for all the
tribal things to just come back.
Cause that's,
there's something deep in us that that's
all embedded in.
I think there's far less of those people
that are allowed for,
that's,
that's done.
Me Too.
And it's so homogenized when he's seen
what they're fucking home depot torches
walking on this tree,
the Tiki torches dorks that the whole
thing was.
So what did you hear Richard Spencer?
He did the,
the,
the white supremacists.
But if he did it,
he did an,
uh,
an interview about two weeks ago where
he was basically saying slavery was good
and all these kinds of things that
British man got the eds and stuff.
They're like,
you're an idiot or whatever.
But I mean it wasn't,
it was,
it was a ridiculous thing to say.
And yet normally,
and you know,
you remember 60 minutes used to have the
KKK white supremacists guys in the old
days on like once a year they didn't,
if you'd like the grand dragon or
whatever and they give them a lot of
airtime and Mike Wallace would question
and at the end of that,
you just always thought the same thing.
These people are idiots,
right?
And you know,
it was the give them enough rope and
they'll hang themselves type journalism.
I thought that that the journalists,
like everybody was talking about that
the guy did the perfect interview with
them.
But I honestly think that's not the way
to do the perfect interview with them.
I think that guy standing up there
standing up facing each other,
I think they'd be far better off if they
sat down.
And if they talked for a long period of
time and I think there's plenty more
rope in that car.
Could've hung them way better.
There's a,
there's a book by a black gentleman who
is a musician,
a Boogie woogie piano player.
I don't remember his name.
This is what is that?
It was a,
it was a book on,
yeah,
but it was a style.
It was a book on the class.
Um,
and,
and he was a guy,
a black man who I'm going from memory
here,
but he likes set up an interview with
one of the heads of the,
of the state clan or whatever.
It didn't tell the guy who was coming
that he was a black man and they have,
so they had this interview and if this
interesting thing he says,
but long story short,
he started to make friends with these
KKK members and it wasn't like rank and
file people.
It was like the Grand Dragon,
whatever.
That's the guy.
How one man convinced 200 Klu Klux Klan
members to give up their roles.
That motherfucker.
But long story short is,
I mean these were the cal Davis.
They didn't have any black people.
They knew,
right?
They had stereotypes and things.
So he said once you're,
like you had said,
when you're face to face with somebody
and you have to interact with them on an
eye to eye level,
it's,
it's very intriguing what he did because
you say to yourself,
okay,
you can never reach these archie bunker
guys,
but people have and do and,
and I do want to say,
listen for all of the white
supremacists,
other than think I'm being unfair,
this racial tribal thing is all over the
place because there are,
you know,
like you will meet black folks who are
racist too.
Now what I always say to people though
is the one thing you have to understand
as a white person that's different is
we're the dominant culture.
Okay?
It does make things different.
If you are a minority in any country,
there's a tendency,
I mean,
you go to the place,
they'll have neighborhoods,
right?
Remember the Italian neighborhoods in
our country,
that Jewish neighborhood,
the Irish neighborhoods,
why did they do that?
Where they racist?
No,
there's,
there's some strength in gathering with
your own kind,
reading your own newspapers and keeping
your culture along language.
That's right.
But,
but it's also a self defense mechanism,
right?
So it's a very different thing to say,
well listen,
there are being racist to okay,
but we're the dominant culture.
And it means that there's something a
little different when we say what's
wrong with saying,
you know,
white people should be proud of their
heritage to theoretically nothing.
But historically speaking,
there are some issues and you need to
recognize that.
Not can we ever get to a time when we
can judge people by the content of their
character.
I don't know.
But I think if,
I think even if white people said we're
going to do that right now,
there'd be people of other colors going,
no,
wait a minute.
We don't want to give up.
Uh,
you know,
some extra admissions into universities
and we don't,
it becomes a very difficult thing to
give up this racial identity.
Um,
in the 60s,
that was the goal.
Now people on all sides,
it'd be,
what are you talking about?
It very,
you know,
the cultural appropriation thing drives
me crazy.
Like if you're going to have dreadlocks,
you can't because that's a black
hairstyle.
What are we want to say is don't black
people want to try different hairstyles
to the cre?
Create creativity is putting things
together that never went together
before.
This is that it's not even a
historically correct.
You know as well as I do,
the dreadlocks had been around for a
long fucking time with white people
about how it just polarizes us even more
if you read this once.
Not Real though is people looking for
things to be polarized.
Yes,
and I,
and again,
I do think and I love academia and I
could've,
I could've got swept up.
I enjoyed school at the college level so
much.
I could still be there today.
I mean,
I've never gotten a job.
I would just be one of those guys.
I'm a graduate student at 51 helping the
professors,
but at the same time,
look,
we all understand that those people are
incentivized to come up with new
theories,
new ideas,
groundbreaking,
cutting edge,
you know,
this is what they're rewarded for with
the carrots and sticks.
So I get it.
It's different when it spreads to the
general culture a little bit though,
because now we're not in the ivory tower
having a theoretical debate.
We're sitting there going,
should that person be shamed on twitter?
Cause he's a Asian person with
dreadlocks.
Okay.
Folks,
if you don't see that might backfire on
you down the road.
I mean,
we've all got to cut each other some
slack on all sides.
If we're gonna make this work.
Well,
it's cultural appropriation is one of
the things that makes America so
fascinating.
Literally the melting pot of humans all
together exploring each other's food
and,
and all the various aspects of their
communities.
The funny part is the cultural
appropriators out there are sometimes
the most sympathetic to that side.
I mean,
if you're willing to get,
uh,
Rastafarians hairstyle,
you're probably not an anti black
racist,
right?
So when you tell them that they
shouldn't be doing that,
aren't you going after the people most
likely to see your side of things and
help you and push angels as to what I'm
saying?
It's almost like we're eating our own on
that.
And on the left,
it is particularly about eating your own
because you can't be progressive enough.
There's always going to be someone who's
more progressive.
And that just how we think,
you know,
when I was a punk back in the old days,
and I remember saying that we're,
we're killing the movement because the
biggest thing was,
was this idea of a poser,
right?
And the first thing everybody said,
we didn't welcome you into the group.
We said,
when did you start wearing these
clothes?
When did you get that hairstyle?
You pose her,
in other words,
the entire thing was exclusive,
right?
So you tried to build this movement,
you have to be an Oji degree.
It was ridiculous.
And then many years you have to be a
punk for before you're allowed to be
upon.
You go in slowly.
I mean,
I remember them,
they were going after like John lied and
Johnny Rotten.
You're a poser.
Okay then what are we doing here?
But I mean in the same way,
the one thing you have to do is cut
people some slack.
And the one thing we human beings seem
to have such a problem with is cutting
people.
Slack and I,
it seems to be,
if you say the social media seems to be
worse because you'll cut somebody slap
face to face more easily than you will.
You know,
when you can just throw 140 characters
and you go to bed.
But that comedian on the other side of
your hundred and 40 characters,
I mean,
let me just,
you've seen this and I've seen this,
but if you've never been on the
receiving end of these things where Pete
and I've been very lucky and people have
been very nice and kind to me,
but even I,
when you read these things,
you go,
who is this person?
Why do they think that this is,
did they,
did their lives get better?
Cause they texted me this.
I mean,
do you see what I'm saying?
I don't get the motivation.
They don't even know it.
They don't even know thinking about it.
They're just acting.
It's a human instinct.
They hurt and they want to hurt others.
They,
that's what you told me years ago.
You told me that that's what,
Hey,
you've helped me a lot when I look at
those things and I think he chose,
right Joe,
this is people that are angry with their
situation and their,
what did,
what did they say?
It's like the crabs in a pot and one
crab crabs in a bucket and you pull the
crab down.
Um,
and it's too bad because you know what?
A lot of those people are the very
people who could be doing much better if
we,
if we could figure out a way to help
empower them to unleash their been
haters that aren't haters anymore.
And unfortunately a lot of people have
already blocked them.
Oh,
just,
just dissatisfied people that are so
upset with the way things are.
I mean I really,
I would love to see more effort made in
that regard because I think the
subsidiary down the road domino effects
would help us all so much.
But listen,
we're a country that can't even get the
most basic things passed.
How are we going to get something like
that done?
I think change is happening.
I think it's happening incredibly
rapidly,
but I think we're stuck in the mix of it
and we don't realize it.
It's sort of like when you come over
someone's house and you haven't been
over there house in like five years and
all of sudden their kid is 10 you're
like,
Holy Shit,
you're 10 now.
To them it just happened gradually and
slowly and they barely have noticed.
Yup.
But to you when you take five years off
and then you see that kid,
you're like,
holy sugar in the hot water.
Right?
It's happening.
It is happening,
but it's just how I see this is where I
can't again in the maelstrom trying to
analysts,
but is it positive or negative?
Now you're an author.
I was just like,
you're an optimist,
Joe.
We'd had this conversation before and
I'm a little bit more cynical and
misanthropic may be.
Um,
but I,
I worry about,
um,
figuring it out.
So if you say that human beings
individually and as groups learn by
mistakes.
Yeah.
So you have to have a Holocaust type
mistake to,
to come out of this before we go.
Wow.
Well,
here's where we screwed up on that
social media thing.
I mean,
I wonder whether we're going to be
allowed.
I would not,
I don't know how you would turn the
genie,
put the genie back in the bottle.
But I mean at what point do terrorists
or dangerous people are,
I mean,
look at the,
to go back to that weather underground
new left bombing thing that I said that
they didn't know the south,
they'd like me,
uh,
waterboarding Abbie Hoffman.
But I mean,
if you'd had a bunch of people back then
with twitter saying,
I support the,
the Abby Hoffman's,
I supported that.
Okay.
At what point would the government first
of all get you on a watch list then?
Or Now?
But at what point would somebody have
said,
listen for our own good,
we can't have average Americans because
look how many terrorists are using this
tool.
I mean,
we'll see what happens.
But you'd mentioned nine 11 and how you
know so much of that they were,
there was a feeling of community and all
that other stuff,
but there was other things too.
There were,
there was the government literally,
and I remember Peter Defazio's,
the congressmen a up in Oregon who said
this to me.
He said,
Dan,
he said there were bills that had been
written and put on a shelf because there
was no way to pass them for the longest
time.
And he goes,
when nine 11 happened,
they pulled all those bills down,
cobbled them into one thing and send it
back.
And then he said,
here's the real scandal.
And most people don't know this.
He says,
do you know how many parts that bill
were blank that we signed to be filled
in later?
He said,
that's not unusual.
He goes,
because we get a lot of bills that they
haven't figured out all the details
because most bills aren't as important.
Is that when he goes,
we signed off to a bunch of things with
a bunch of blank categories to be filled
in later.
Okay.
It gets us back to leadership right
there.
What's wrong with the country?
A bunch of people signing a bunch of
stuff that have nothing in it yet.
Like I said before,
when you're talking about it,
like are you optimistic?
Are you pessimistic?
Is it negative or is it positive?
It's both.
And I think the negative and the
positive are both necessary.
I don't think we're gonna live in this
utopian world where everybody's just
friendly to each other.
I think people are going to make
mistakes.
They're going to be shitty.
They're going to realize that their
shitty and the understanding of that
behavior and the ramifications of that
behavior is becoming more and more
apparent every day.
And I think we're seeing that and I
think we're caught up in this storm and
there's a fucking hurricane going on
man.
This cows by and bathtubs
in the air.
All this stuff is happening right now.
The hope is though that we could get to
the good cause.
I might agree with you at the long term,
right?
If you're saying optimistic real long
term,
but how many,
I mean if you said in 1900 I'm
optimistic long term that by the year
2000 things will be better.
Yes.
But you have two world wars to go
through in the interim and the nude near
misses on nuclear wars.
So I can agree with you that long term
we may have a positive outcome here.
I don't know what our immediate short
term with you and I have 2030 40 you
probably have a hundred years left on
your lifespan,
but some of us are not in great shape.
So I'm hunt.
She said the next 2025 30 years,
are you going to see good or bad from
this?
We may have to go through some learning
experiences and those tend to not be so
fun to live through.
Yeah,
there's that.
But also there's like how bout just
disengaged from that?
Every now and then.
I agree with you.
Don't have your life completely
dependent upon the success and failures
of other people's emotions and ideas
like it.
Just go off on your own more often.
Spend more time by yourself,
more time pursuing your own activity.
Spend more time in nature with your
phone off.
Spend more time,
really good idea to cause giant.
Yes,
and you know what?
Because folks,
that's what connects you to all the
other human beings who ever lived before
us.
That the,
the,
the thing that makes our time period
different here,
this vast human experiment is we've
never had a generation growing up with
mobile phones,
for example.
What does that mean?
Well,
one thing it does is it takes you away
from the part that your aunts,
I mean looking up at a night sky with
nothing to do for hours,
just sitting there contemplating the
silence or the rustling of the trees or
whatever.
I don't know if you get anything out of
that or not,
but that's something that human beings
have done since caveman times that
you're sharing an experience that's
innately human.
If that becomes less and less common
because we're detached from that.
Does that mean,
and we'd,
like I said,
we talked about an experiment earlier,
that we're an experiment.
What does it mean when people detach
from that part of the human existence to
spend more time in this new part of
human existence?
I don't know.
Well,
I think that part of being a person,
like being in nature is an,
it's part of us.
It's part of how we developed.
It's attached to our human reward
system.
There's something that's deeply
satisfying about lying down in a field
and looking up at the stars.
And there's a reason for all that.
And the more we detach from that,
the more you're going to get these
disenfranchised,
very unhappy people that feel like
they're a prisoner or a slave to some
system that doesn't give a fuck about
them.
Cause it doesn't,
it really doesn't.
What the people that give a fuck about
you or your community,
they're your friends.
The,
the,
the community of likeminded humans that
you've bonded with that share your
occupation or share your interests.
And that's how people develop satisfying
relationships.
And satisfying lives.
The more you put yourself connected to
something that doesn't even value you.
Some huge monolithic creation that's,
there's no one even running it.
It's not like some architect has figured
out a great to design civilization
to satisfy all the humans that are a
part of it.
No,
you're feeding this machine and some
sort of a weird way that nobody really
understands the ramifications of because
we haven't done it before.
There hasn't been this global connection
of cell phones for thousands of years.
We know how to manage it.
We know how to manage your time and all
your,
your emotions on social media now.
This is all,
this is all experimental.
It's all happening in the moment and
we're all a part of it.
And what's it going to be like three
generations from now?
I'm scared.
I'm scared that we're eliminating as
much as possible boredom from our lives
because I think the boredom is
important.
Um,
when I was a kid,
we talked about being weird when I was a
kid,
um,
had a lot of free time on my hands.
Had to figure out ways to entertain
myself,
no video games.
And you,
you,
you end up doing things that like,
um,
you know,
you had talked about your whole,
we found this niche for me and this
history show thing cause it's what I was
born to do or whatever.
Yes.
But,
but it goes back to me trying to figure
out,
okay,
I've played with these toy plastic
soldiers,
uh,
every single day,
how do I make something new so that I
can be entertained with these same toy
soldier?
You know?
And I think that all,
you know,
if we think about building blocks in
your brain,
the need to overcome boredom,
for example,
is a prime mover.
When you're young,
you're not motivated by money,
you're not motivate.
It's,
it's,
you're not even motivated by,
by the opposite sex.
You know,
when you're a kid,
you're like,
what am I going to do to fill this
afternoon?
And you find ways to,
you know,
I remember tearing up my mom's garden
wants to create a giant river system,
you know?
Yeah.
But would you do that today?
Was even bothered,
took hours.
I mean I would,
but maybe a kid would.
Maybe there's,
maybe there's an app where you can do
it.
Do the,
do the same thing on my point is,
is that there's these sorts of prime
movers end up creating their needs that
create the need for solutions.
If you get rid of that need,
do you need the solution anymore?
And did,
did the,
did the need for the solution create a
different Joe Rogan Dan Carlin or Joe
blow out on the street then would have
been otherwise we've talked about
creating a more formidable human being,
having to overcome my childhood boredom
created a more formidable human being.
It did Dan Carlin,
we just did three hours again,
just went flying by.
Always done.
It always does.
We got to do this more often.
We always say this,
but can we please,
I may.
I may do a book soon.
It was,
you'd like to have a stress stupid book
tour interview and are you gonna do
that?
I don't know.
Same,
same time the virtual reality comes out.
Let's please sit down and talk more
often.
I'm really,
I really enjoy it.
Can I just tell you,
you're one of the most open minded
people though,
and I do quote you at times because
you've taught me a lot.
Oh,
thank you brother.
And you've taught me a lot too.
I appreciate it.
Dan Carlin,
ladies and gentlemen,
hardcore history.
Go download,
subscribe.
Bye.
You do know.